yes
so
like
it's
felix
now
right
hmm
thanks out there yes
good morning welcome
how's everyone doing great yeah i mean
this is a exciting day for two reasons
one we have an amazing lineup
and second i think it's just really
exciting that
we are on the eve of the launch of the
affordable care act in connecticut and
that's really what we're going to be
talking about today i want to start
with a few thank yous and
there are so many people who helped make
this event possible and i can't thank
them all but i want to thank some of
them and who have really contributed to
the effort um first laurie hirschman uh
torrey bilsky lamor pierre pam lamonica
cheryl tappin
from isps um also the tech personnel
here carl patterson peterson and raymond
mckeon uh have been just amazing in in
making this uh setup possible we are
live casting this event um as well as
recording it uh for a future
viewing
i also want to thank our co-sponsors for
the event uh senator chris murphy's
office um joe dunn uh has done an
enormous amount of work with us and lee
reynolds joanne cannon and megan
forgione are here today i hope you get a
chance to talk with them um now
as if you haven't noticed already
if you haven't noticed already uh
senator chris murphy uh is not here um
he regrets he can't come he's uh going
to join us by video um later today um
there was i guess a very long speech on
the senate floor
that delayed him um i can promise you my
introduction is going to be a lot
shorter than that um but i can't go on
without thanking pam greene who really
uh has made this conference uh possible
she is an amazing organizer a wonderful
person to work with and
she's really shown herself to be able to
adapt to almost any challenge
we had senator murphy's uh inability to
come we had the railroad shut down
and uh my
colleague in in producing this event
zach cooper who's going to speak next uh
noted that we're just waiting for the
locusts to arrive uh if we if we got
them i'm sure pm could take could take
care of them um
so
and by the way i i don't think ted cruz
had anything to do with the uh with the
railroad problems but um i'm looking
into it okay so the twitterratty were
all a flutter about senator cruz's
reading of green eggs and ham on the
senate floor
here's one happy tea party tweet that i
saw i do not like obamacare sam i am i
would not fund it in a box
i would not fund it with a fox
now
i'm not the first person to note as a uh
a parent of children who once to whom i
once read green eggs and ham that ted
cruz
failed to get the moral of green eggs
and ham um i can't do this by memory
anymore i used to be able to read it
while asleep um
but i'm gonna just read the crucial
passage in green eggs and ham i do not
like green eggs and ham i do not like
them sam-i-am you do not like them so
you say try them try them and you may
try them and you may i say
sam if you will let me be
i will try them you will
see say
i like green eggs and ham
i do
i like them sam i am
okay so i cannot promise we're gonna
have we're not gonna have a shutdown in
fact i'm pretty sure we're going to or a
debt ceiling breach or a constitutional
crisis but i can promise that
connecticut and many other states will
be tasting green eggs and ham
in the near future and i think they're
going to like it
and this conference is really about what
green eggs and ham are going to taste
like
long since the battles of 2010 we now
face the moment of truth for the
affordable care act and as we'll see
connecticut is moving forward
very
aggressively to implement the law fully
we're going to learn about the two key
parts of the affordable care act uh that
that are under discussion today the
exchanges
that are allowing people to purchase
private insurance who don't get it
through their place of work and the
expansion of medicaid we're also going
to talk about the key overarching goal
of the affordable care act uh how to
reduce
the
america's uh meteoric rise in health
care costs um we've spent vastly more
than any other nation on health care uh
and although it's those costs have
moderated uh in recent years um the
long-term trend is is dramatic and the
greatest fiscal threat that our country
faces not to mention a huge burden on
american business and families um so we
are connecticut is one of 16 states uh
with its own exchanges there's also a
district of columbia 17 states the rest
are within various kinds of partnership
with the federal government uh i use
partnership as a euphemism in in some
cases because the federal government is
basically doing it for states that
aren't moving forward um we're going to
have exchanges in all of the 50 states
plus the district of columbia and it
looks as if the premiums in those states
according to a new report from the
department of health and human services
are going to be lower than substantially
lower than expected
after taking tax credits into account
for example 56 percent of uninsured
americans according to this new report
nearly six and ten are going to qualify
for health coverage in the marketplace
for less than a hundred dollars per
person
per month
that's including medicaid and s-chip and
as i know
most of you recognize
that's despite the fact that
half the states
are not currently planning to expand
their medicaid programs the supreme
court of course left open that
possibility and there is a feature of
the law that is somewhat less understood
than the fact that lots of states aren't
moving forward which is that people with
incomes above 100
below 100 of the poverty line are not
eligible for subsidies
within the exchange and so in those
states that have yet decided to expand
as many as two of five adults who are
uninsured for any time over the last two
years are not going to have access to
the new coverage provisions in the law
unless states start to move forward so i
think it's very important for us to
think
about the extent to which the early
examples of states that move forward and
the pressure that's brought to bear on
states that have not are going to change
that difficult equation when it comes to
medicaid i can't think of a better event
to mark
the the new year for the institution for
social and policy studies and the launch
of the isps health initiative
isps is all about advancing research
that speaks to important policy problems
and shaping the next generation of
leaders on these issues and
isps health is really a model of how
that can be done zach cooper is going to
tell you more about isps health which
launches like the affordable care act
with
this fall and i should just say that
zach is a health economist at the school
of public health and also a resident
fellow at isps
he's also
a faculty associate at this at the
london school of economic center that
center at c-e-n-t-r-e
for economic performance so zach
do you like green eggs and ham
come on
so hi everybody welcome thanks for uh
pump that forward thanks for coming it's
absolutely extraordinary to see this
many people coming out to an event
on health policy i mean for those of us
who work in it this is this is
absolutely fantastic it's incredibly
cool um we're talking about two launches
today
and the first is the launch of the
affordable care act
think about what that means and what the
implications are for connecticut
residents
and the second launches as jacob alluded
to is the launch of isps health which i
will be
directing with an executive team with
abby glock mata kowalski jacob and susan
bush
for my own career prospects i'm hoping
it's sort of deeply
less controversial
than the affordable care act that would
be unfortunate if it was
you know our ability as a country
our fiscal future is really a function
of our ability to constrain healthcare
spending
it's bankrupting this country
and our goal as isps health
is to use research to mobilize all the
extraordinary academics and and all the
resources at yale
to provide research to drive
evidence-based policy that's what we
want to do we've got three aims
we want to
be able to connect our scholars
to the outside world
we want a community where medical school
professors and economists come together
to say how do we address these problems
and we want to empower our students who
are
absolutely going to be the ones taking
care of jacob and i when we're old and
hopefully creating a health care system
that we can benefit
from know i i think
you know in many ways this type of event
is exactly what we want to do
take advantage of the best yale has to
offer and hopefully improve the lives of
the folks outside of the yale community
be able to improve people's lives
so i want to echo jacob and and thank
all the people who went in in particular
pam green who can we just give her a
quick round of
you apps jacob and i last night were
sort of nervously emailing at 10 30 and
then i i went to sleep i was asleep by
11 30. i checked my inbox this morning
and there are emails still flowing in
from from pam green so this this
absolutely wouldn't have been possible
without her
so
you know i said students are important
our first event was an infographic
contest
so what we did was we asked the student
body
to create an infographic
that talked about how young people could
enroll
and why it was important okay this was
sort of our our first effort to get the
undergrads involved or the the students
grad students all involved and they did
an extraordinary job so originally it
was going to be
chris murphy presenting the awards he's
going to tweet them so this is this is
okay
he unfortunately isn't here to present
them so i wanted to to present the
awards to uh the students who did such
an extraordinary job and and show you
their infographics which we're going to
post out there
uh we'll be tweeting and i hope you guys
take a look at so the third place was
nina russell and benjamin weisler let's
see if we can
we can find this so this was their their
infographic come on up so we give them a
50 amazon gift certificate here we go
so nina nina is also my research
assistant which means that if i didn't
get her a prize my sort of research
agenda is is sunk um but no she did an
extraordinary job so in second place is
jason kim clinton wang and bobo zang who
really had a beautiful piece that talks
about how young people
want to enroll i mean this is this is
phenom and this is exactly what we want
to do
we get folks here involved
in the aca
have it be non-partisan
and we we don't think reading x and hand
is what's going to solve what's going on
you know we think that it's informing
the public about what works and what
doesn't and letting them decide
themselves so thank you guys for for
doing this here's that
and then this this monstrosity
this is it was supposed to fit on one
single page um we made an exception
because it's
absolutely fantastic um so the winners
are it's going to be sydney shea and
jack newsham so thank you guys so much
so now we're going to
give you guys these and we're going to
transition into our first panel which is
about unpacking what is actually
in the aca i mean i think that's
extraordinary if we look at public
polling about the extent first of all
most people 40 don't even know that it's
a law
let alone what's in it so the first
panel is going to be saying what's in
the affordable care act what does it
mean and what do we learn from
massachusetts that can tell us what we
can expect
in connecticut so i was originally going
to turn the the panel over to chris
murphy who was going to give a an
opening address
ted cruz
got a little bit in the way of that
and uh and senator murphy's still down
in dc actually doing a funding vote
that's hinging
on the aca
so the the argument was we should defund
the aca in order to continue funding the
government and so he's there on a vote
to
hopefully keep that from from getting
defunded so this is topical
this is this is the issues that we're
talking about right now so that i'm
going to invite amanda kowalski and abby
glock up and we'll transition into our
first panel so thank you guys for coming
yes i'll introduce so abby um
the first speaker's gonna be abby gluck
who's an associate professor here at the
law school
what you're gonna see is that the the
backgrounds of the speakers are pretty
exceptional so abby
uh was also an undergrad here which is
ex and and went to yale law school come
back
you're a lifer so she's an associate
professor at the law school she was a
clerk for ruth bitter ginsburg and the
supreme court was an associate at paul
weiss and then worked in both the
bloomberg and corzine administrations so
an extraordinary example of combining
policy and rigorous scholarship so
abby's going to tell us a little bit
about what's
actually in this
cool welcome
great perfect and here's your quicker
going
let me just test this out make sure i
know how to do it
yeah perfect
um
okay so thanks for having me uh it's a
very exciting day to be here at yale for
two reasons because we're launching the
affordable care act and we're also
launching isps and i am really thrilled
to be part of isps health that is not
sps i am really thrilled to be part of
that team and very excited about this
project so as zach said my job here is
to introduce you to the affordable care
act recognizing there are different
levels of expertise in the room also
recognizing that this statute is 2 000
pages long weighs more than my youngest
daughter does and so i am going to have
to give you the broad brush strokes the
most important structural elements of
the act while also asking you to keep in
mind there's a lot of other stuff in
there that's going to be important over
time
some of that stuff are things like
incentives to get more primary care
doctors out there stuff like calorie
counts on menus and chain restaurants or
now your child's vaccines are going to
be paid for by insurance my children's
vaccines were not paid for by insurance
for the last seven years so that's a
nice welcome development
um but i'm going to focus on the big
picture and in particular i want to
emphasize three overarching points
the first thing i want to emphasize is
that
the main goal of this statute
is getting as many americans insured as
possible right health reform is often
referred to healthcare is often referred
to as a three-legged stool quality costs
and access being the three legs
and the aca does have some very
important reforms aimed at quality
control and cost access much of which
professor kowalski is going to talk
about right after me
but the point i want to make is that the
overarching philosophy of this statute
is that the first thing you have to do
is get everybody into the system before
that other stuff can follow i'm going to
talk a little bit about how the act does
that the second point i want to
emphasize is that although this statute
is discussed as radical reform the way
it accomplishes this overarching goal of
getting everybody in is by expanding
familiar programs
and i think understanding the act is a
combination one place that hosts
different structures that we're all
familiar with brings a lot of clarity to
the act to people who might not
understand the details so i'm going to
do that in a second
and finally the third point to highlight
and the reason we're here today in
connecticut having this connecticut
focus conference is that the act puts
states on the forefront of implementing
it um and that's also something that's
always been the case in this country
the states have always been the
frontline implementers of healthcare and
health regulation so with that overview
let me talk about how the aca
accomplishes its main goal of getting
everybody in short
before health reform
most americans got their health
insurance coverage in one of three ways
right you either got it through your
employer more than half the country
pretty much did that including more than
half of the citizens in connecticut or
you got it through the federal
government through one of the special
federal programs medicare for the
elderly medicaid for certain needy
populations the veterans health care
system and so on or you're an individual
you went out and you bought it yourself
there of course is another category of
people who didn't buy health insurance
at all some of them played that paid out
of pocket right and others went and
still got treated even if they couldn't
afford to pay but hospitals and free
clinics absorbed the cost of that
uninsured care
now what the akka does is that it just
expands each of these pre-existing
structures and also aims to eliminate
that fourth category of people who are
uninsured
so if you're somebody who might get your
health insurance from an employer what
the act does is it tries to incentivize
more employers to provide health
insurance by penalizing large employers
who don't do it and by incentivizing
with tax incentives small employers to
do it
if you got your health insurance from
the federal government the actor works a
dramatic expansion or tries to work i'll
explain why it tries to work a dramatic
expansion of medicare and medicaid
um
i'll start with medicare
less dramatic than medicare i'll explain
this donut in a minute uh
medicare is a health insurance program
for the elderly and disabled and until
and the main reform and health reform is
an expansion of prescription drug
coverage under medicare
until health reform the way prescription
drug coverage worked is that you paid
for drugs medicare paper drugs up to a
certain rather low level then seniors
had to kick in and pay for those drugs
in the middle and then if the levels got
to a catastrophic amount medicare came
back and kicked in again one of the most
important reforms to medicare in the
health reform bill is that there's going
to be continuous coverage of
prescription drugs that's why they call
it closing the doughnut hole of medicaid
which explains this rather odd picture
of a restaurant called the doughnut hole
in texas that i was able to find at 11
pm last night i am the person who is
emailing pam green at 11 p.m last night
guilty so um now let me go on to
medicaid
the expansion of medicaid which is again
the government insurance program for the
needy was supposed to be much more
dramatic
uh
i know there's varied expertise in the
room so i'm not going to ask for a show
of hands but i want you to ask yourself
this question before health reform do
you think that a childless man at a very
low level of poverty was eligible for
medicaid i think a lot of people think
the answer is yes the answer is actually
no in a lot of states federal law didn't
only require that medicaid be covered by
the states for certain special needy
populations basically pregnant women
mothers with dependent children some
states like connecticut like new york
voluntarily extended that medicaid
coverage to other populations but it was
not a federal right health reform tried
to change that the law passed by
congress would have extended medicaid to
138 of the poverty level no matter who
you were
uh the reason i say health reform tried
to change this is because the supreme
court intervened last year uh and held
that congress could not order the states
to expand medicaid in this way and that
it has to be optional right so as a
result
what we have is as uh jacob mentioned
about half the states including
connecticut have agreed to expand
medicaid
and although there was initial
resistance in the other half of the
states
um
particularly from republican-controlled
states
i want to make the case that that tide
is turning right the
health care is very expensive medicaid
is a very good deal for the states
federal government picks up a huge
amount of the cost if the feds don't do
it states are going to have to pay for
it on their own dime
over the course of this summer a lot of
republican governors recognize the
financial realities of this situation
and have gone to their states and
basically begged them to expand medicaid
my prediction is that over time we're
going to see almost all of the states
expanding medicaid in some way not
everyone but i think we're going to have
majority over time
i could be wrong about that that's my uh
that's my prediction finally uh the last
critical reform applies to those who buy
their own insurance or choose not to buy
it at all the aca makes major reforms to
the private insurance market that are
designed to make insurance more
affordable and cheaper these are the
things that have been in the media a lot
right the so-called guaranteed issue and
community rating requirements which just
means you can't get turned down for
health insurance and you can't be
charged more because you're not as
healthy as the next guy
um
those requirements are expensive for
insurers to absorb so congress need to
find a way to offset that cost how did
it do that with the most controversial
and novel part of the bill the so-called
individual mandate the idea that every
american the requirement not the idea
the requirement that every american must
get themselves insured or they have to
pay a tax penalty
the idea is to bring more people into
the insurance pool including more
healthy people thus bringing the cost
down for everyone but i'm going to leave
the economics to the professor and keep
going with the structure of the law
finally the act creates these health
insurance exchanges which are one-stop
shop shopping portals for insurance i
think the best analogy is expedia where
you get to compare prices
um the idea is that there's more uh
transparent and the more transparent
competition is another way to drive down
the cost of insurance and additionally
as jacob mentioned the federal
government is going to provide subsidies
if you make up to 400 000 up to make up
to 400 of the poverty level which is
basically 50 000 a year 90 000 for a
family of four to help you buy insurance
on those insurance exchanges so notably
the supreme court did not invalidate the
mandate despite that true statistic that
zach relayed saying that 40 of americans
think the health care reform was struck
down the supreme court actually held the
mandate with a valid exercise of
congress's commerce power it's going
into effect in 2014 which is why we've
got these health insurance exchanges
launched we're going to hear about that
on the next panel so i'm going to move
on to the role of this days but before i
do that i want to make a few overarching
policy observations
from a policy perspective you might be
thinking this patchwork of insurance
mechanisms doesn't make a lot of sense
if the goal is to make things more
efficient and bring down costs after all
we've got several different government
programs involved states and feds and
we've also got a whole separate area of
laws designed to regulate the still
existing private insurance system
and you know it's absolutely true that
many health policy experts for a long
time have lamented this fragmented
structure of how health care is paid for
and delivered in the united states
um
and in terms of how health care is paid
for uh let me offer one example my
favorite example is of an airplane
ticket when you buy a ticket to fly to
texas to visit ted cruz and tell them to
stop talking on the side of the floor
when you buy that ticket uh you buy a
ticket you don't pay one price you don't
pay for the flight attendants the guys
who rush the one way the guys who clean
the seats right you buy the gasoline pay
for one ticket when i had all three of
my children i paid a bunch of different
bills i paid the anesthesiologist the ob
the hospital and so on i'm sure
everybody's had the same experience you
pay a doctor's bill then you get the
separate bill like what is this where's
this who's this for right uh
truly radical reform might have tried to
remedy these problems both the
structural fragmentation and the way we
pay for health care
for example everybody in the same kind
of insurance system or let's come up
with episode of care payments for single
visits uh but with respect to the kind
of structural fragmentation the medicare
medicaid private insurance fragmentation
there's no political viability right now
in this country for that kind of reform
it's just too radical the idea of
medicare for all is too radical and so
the kind of path dependent but very
important major expansion that we had
was perhaps the very best that congress
could have done under the circumstances
with respect to the second kind of
fragmentation that i mentioned my uh
birth ex birth and all other health care
experiences um
there are reforms in the akka that are
designed to um
hold on i do there are reforms in the
act that are designed to test out these
kinds of bundling mechanisms mechanisms
payments for single uh episodes of care
things called accountable care
organizations which are organizations
designed to incentivize doctors to
cooperate horizontally across
specialties coordinate care across
patients and save money
very famous successful groups of doctors
like the mayo clinic in minnesota are
the inspirations for these kinds of
reforms and hopefully it will generate
data
from which we'll be able to see where
the industry should go
um
okay so professor kowalski is going to
talk about evidence on the ground about
the potential benefits of all these
interventions so where i want to
conclude right now is just to mention
the role of the states since that's part
of our focus today and then touch on
three important challenges ahead
so as i said earlier the states are at
the forefront of the law that's been our
american tradition traits avoid states
have always controlled insurance health
care charity care health regulation uh
and the reasons for that have been the
traditional federalism reasons that
lawyers like to talk about the idea that
different geographic regions need to
have different solutions the idea that
experimentation across 50 states is
better than experimentation just alone
in the federal government and the idea
that state governments are smaller more
responsive to the particular needs of
their citizens so the aca let's be fair
does take some of the state control away
it federalizes a heck of a lot of
insurance law for the first time
on the other hand it gives back to the
states a huge opportunity to be at the
forefront of shaping what the statute
looks like in their particular states
states can apply for special ways to
implement medicaid some states are
basically privatizing medicaid other
states like connecticut are expanding it
within the current structure states are
also the default implementers of those
health insurance exchanges and the idea
was that the states could decide what
insurers they were going to let on to
their exchange how they were going to
market those exchanges to their citizens
and in fact that was exactly what the
state power proponents in congress
wanted they wanted states on the front
line but now again because of the
particularly divisive politics of the
situation you've got traditionally state
power oriented states refusing to
implement the state exchanges that
doesn't mean they're not going to get
exchanges that means the federal
government is going to come in and
operate exchanges in those states hope
you can all see the irony in this right
the states that didn't want the federal
intervention or the ones that are having
the federal government running their
insurance systems right now on the other
hand states like connecticut that are
implementing the exchanges and are
making connecticut specific reforms are
taking the lead in shaping the statute
the way they want it's a complete flip
of the usual federalism dynamics that we
have in this country extremely
interesting if you study federalism and
healthcare um so let me just conclude
now by mentioning a few big challenges
ahead of us
first obviously politics
the house has voted 40 times to repeal
the statute
it's not getting repealed that's not
going to get through the senate that's
not going to get through the president
but the thing has to get funded
right and it has to get through the
house to get properly funded so funding
is a challenge
uh second of the related challenges that
the federal government now faces and
getting these exchanges off the ground i
think it's fair to say that nobody
expected the feds to be operating more
than half of the exchanges precisely
because all the state power proponents
wanted to operate the exchanges
themselves i think people are actually
pleasantly surprised that the feds have
stepped up and done what seems to be a
fairly good job and seem to be ready to
get these things open uh time will tell
but it's still a huge lift even though
they seem to have been successful thus
far
and the third and last challenge is
outreach this is a statute that depends
on people coming out of the woodwork
right people have to get themselves
insured and take advantage of all the
benefits and people are worried that
some of the states just won't do the
kind of outreach necessary because maybe
on purpose because they kind of oppose
the act or maybe some stations don't
have their act together uh effectively
to reach all these these populations
connecticut i think is an outlier in
that regard they've done some pretty
fantastic outreach efforts which i know
we're going to hear about in the second
panel but it's a challenge for the rest
of the country that i want to just
mention before i conclude uh so with
that uh 2000 pages in 15 minutes i'm
gonna turn the podium over to professor
kowalski thanks
so
much amanda kowalski is our next speaker
she's a professor of economics here at
yale she also really is the leader
in studying what happened in
massachusetts and telling us what that
means for
the rest of the country she had two
cents on the council of economic
advisors at the white house and we'll
turn it over to amanda um a brief sort
of programming note you know this is a
new sort of event for us
this really is about
a dialogue and and us
not saying whether the affordable care
act is good or bad but but what the
research shows and letting you guys make
up your minds so with that in mind we're
going to be passing out note cards and
we encourage you guys to write questions
we'll collect those note cards and then
try to answer as many questions as we
can during the
during the panels
amanda thank you very much for that
introduction
so
i have spent a lot of time studying what
happened in the state of massachusetts
in their health reform that was passed
in 2006 and i think that particularly
since the massachusetts health reform
was very similar to what's in the
affordable care act and since a lot of
the affordable care act will be
implemented in the states there's a lot
to learn from massachusetts so in the
course of my time with you i'll just
give a very very brief overview of how
the massachusetts health reform was
similar to the affordable care act since
we've already had an introduction to the
affordable care act with professor gluck
then i'll show you what the impact was
on coverage and then i'll talk about the
impact of health reform on three other
outcomes the impact on hospital and
preventive care the impact on the labor
market and the impact on adverse
selection in the individual health
insurance market so first what was in
massachusetts health reform
so massachusetts health reform was
passed in april of 2006 under then
governor mitt romney and it included
five different features to get people
into health insurance coverage an
individual mandate that individuals must
have health insurance or pay a penalty
an employer mandate that employers must
offer coverage or pay a penalty
expansions in traditional medicaid
coverage expansions in new subsidized
but not free coverage and then reforms
to the health insurance exchanges and as
you see on the right side of this figure
the affordable care act has those same
five initiatives to expand health
insurance coverage and in addition it
also includes some cost control measures
which weren't really a feature of the
massachusetts health reform
so before i show you that there was an
impact on the labor market or on the
individual health insurance market a
first order consideration is really did
the reform succeed in getting people
covered and so here are some figures
that here's one figure that shows that
yes massachusetts health reform did get
people covered the top dashed blue line
gives health insurance coverage in the
state of massachusetts from before to
after the reform and the bottom solid
red line gives health insurance coverage
nationally one thing that you will
notice is that massachusetts was
different from other states it had a
higher level of coverage than other
states do
but then you'll also notice that after
implementation coverage expanded
dramatically it was about a fifty
percent reduction in the rate of
uninsurance which amounted to about six
percentage points of the population
getting health insurance coverage
because health insurance coverage in
massachusetts was already so high before
the reform
we actually expect that there'll be a
much larger impact on coverage
nationally when the affordable care act
is implemented
i also want to point out that even
though there were lots of concerns that
employers might drop coverage in
response to the
massachusetts health reform about 50 of
that increase in coverage came through
employers and the other 50
came from increase in public sources and
and we'll talk about the impact on the
labor market a little bit more but my
co-author jonathan colstad and i predict
that actually we might even see more
take-up of employer-sponsored health
insurance under the affordable care act
than there was in massachusetts because
of some of the incentives built into
that legislation
so i promise that we'll talk about some
of our research papers so on to the
first paper this is joint with my
co-author jonathan colstadt who's a
professor at wharton
and in this paper we examined what
happened to hospital and preventive care
in massachusetts relative to other
states after the reform relative to
before reform and so we examine a
variety of outcomes using hospital data
and we find that in the hospitals length
of stay decreased and that was
consistent with patients having better
access to follow-up care and doctors
being more less reluctant to discharge
them length of stay particularly
decreased the the most for the longest
stairs
then also consistent with patients
getting better access to primary care we
saw that hospital admissions from the
emergency room decreased so that's also
consistent with patients having access
to better care we saw that some measures
of prevention improved there are some
things that people just shouldn't be
showing up at the hospital for if they
have adequate access to primary care
such as perforated appendices adult
asthma episodes
lower extremity amputation for people
with extreme diabetes we saw some of
these measures improved in the very
short term even though we would like to
see longer-term impacts on prevention
that's what we saw in the short term and
then we examine what happened to
hospital costs and even though hospital
costs were growing on a higher on a
higher trajectory in massachusetts than
they were in other states
before the reform they remained on that
trajectory so we didn't see
the the cost curve bending either
direction in massachusetts
and that's important to note that in the
massachusetts health reform there
weren't actually any cost control
measures even though there are some cost
control measures
under the affordable care act so what do
these findings imply for what we might
see in the affordable care act and what
we might see in connecticut well it's
likely that the expansions to near
universal coverage will come with better
access to primary care
which might manifest itself in lower
length of stays fewer admissions from
the emergency room and fewer admissions
to the hospitals for preventable
illnesses and then we think it's likely
it's unlikely to raise hospital costs
beyond their predicted growth rate
although of course there are several
caveats that massachusetts is very
different from other states
and there there could be several things
that differ but still it's probably the
best place that we can look
on to our second paper what was the
impact of massachusetts health reform on
the labor market in this paper we
develop a model of how the individual
mandate and the employer mandate and the
subsidized coverage through medicaid and
the exchanges impacts the supply of of
workers and the demand for workers and
then using that theory we bring the
theory to massachusetts and church and
test the empirical magnitudes and then
we say what that will imply for the
implementation of the affordable care
act
in brief what we found is if anything
the aggregate labor market was
unaffected
if you step back and think about this
that's perhaps not so surprising because
i showed you on the
results about coverage that it was about
six percentage points of the population
gained health insurance coverage through
the reform and so for that those six
percentage points of the of the
population to have an impact on the
aggregate labor market there would have
to be just a huge impact on their labor
market outcomes and so we don't really
see much happening on the aggregate
labor market in terms of the number of
employees the hours worked
and those types of measures but for
those people who switched into
employer-sponsored health insurance from
before the reform to after the reform we
saw that their wages go down
and then how do we interpret this nobody
likes decreased wages but decreased
wages here might actually indicate that
these employees value the health
insurance that they receive receiving
through their employers and therefore
they were willing to accept lower wages
from their employers
another implication of this is that even
though we hear a lot in the media about
employers being reluctant to
satisfy the employer mandate and to
offer coverage through their employees
because they don't want to pay the bill
it appears that the employees themselves
were effectively paying the bill for
their increased health insurance through
the decrease that they experienced in
wages and using our
economic modeling framework we find that
the individuals who took up
employer-sponsored health insurance
coverage in massachusetts valued it at
around 75 cents on the dollar if they
had valued at 100 cents on the dollar or
more than they would have had it in the
first place um valuing it so highly
though means that the
the distortion to the labor market was
much smaller than it otherwise would
have been if the government had said uh
had instead perhaps taxed
wages to provide health insurance
so we do expect that under national
reform we we won't see huge aggregate
impacts on the labor market but we do
expect that individuals who take up
coverage through their employers will
see decreases in wages if they value the
health insurance that they receive
through their employers
then finally i'd like to talk about two
more papers that i've written with
jonathan colstad and also with a
graduate student at yale martin hackman
on what happened in the individual
health insurance market and in this
paper we focus on the individual health
insurance market which is defined as the
market for anyone purchasing health
insurance outside of the their employers
and we develop a model of how the
individual mandate should have an impact
on this market
and then we examine that theory in
massachusetts
in in massachusetts there were guarantee
issue and community rating regulations
in place which professor gluck already
discussed which means that
insurers had to charge the same price to
all comers and they had to offer health
insurance to all comers before the
reform there are six states that also
have those community rating and
guarantee issue regulations in place
including the state of connecticut
one disadvantage of those regulations is
that if insurers have to charge
everybody the same price the people who
are really going to want to purchase
health insurance are going to be the
sick people but the health insurers know
that the people who really are coming to
them to purchase health insurance are
the sick people so they charge a very
high average price and then the people
who are healthy when they go to the
insurers they see a price that's that
high and they decide this is too
expensive for me i can't purchase
coverage in economics we call this
phenomena an adverse election and the
result of adverse election is that
because prices for everybody at the same
price they end up being high prices and
it's the people that would
have very low medical expenditures that
go without coverage this problem was
particularly salient in the individual
health insurance market it's actually
one of the textbook cases in economics
where we think there could be adverse
election and it's particularly even more
pronounced perhaps in states that have
these guarantee issue and community
rating regulations
so what did we do we examined what
happened to coverage premiums and the
average cost to the insurers in
massachusetts relative to other states
from before to after reform and the
results are actually very striking so
this is a case where textbook economics
is actually at work
so first when we examine what happened
to health insurance coverage you'll see
that in the individual health insurance
market coverage was actually much lower
than it was elsewhere in the state
because a lot of people get health
insurance through their employers and
because these regulations were
particularly binding in the individual
health insurance market so in that top
dash blue line you see that
massachusetts started out with a rate of
about 70 percent coverage in the
individual health insurance market and
that went up to about 95
from before the reform to after the
reform
and so there was a really big impact on
coverage and getting that individual
mandate implemented and getting those
other insurance market reforms
and so it seems that the individual
mandate get did get people into the
market and then also particularly
striking is what happened to premiums so
on the right side of this you'll see
that premiums were higher in
massachusetts than they were in other
states that's likely because of the
regulations that were in place in the
individual health insurance market in
massachusetts but then you'll also see
that those premiums fell in dollar terms
from before the reform to after the
reform on the magnitude of about twenty
percent starting from about six thousand
dollars a year so we're talking about
real money that uh the premiums actually
fell by
and then furthermore
ensure expenditures decreased which
really gives us concrete evidence that
there was adverse selection in the
reform and that the implementation of
the massachusetts health reform with its
individual mandate and its insurance
market reforms actually increased well
for welfare for citizens of
massachusetts so how do we how do we
quantify this welfare and what do we
think that this means for
citizens of connecticut and other people
affected by the implementation of the
affordable care act i just want to step
back and say i expect the massachusetts
results here to generalize fairly well
to the state of connecticut i do expect
that premiums will go down in the state
of connecticut in the individual health
insurance market
and then when we quantify what was the
welfare gain from reducing adverse
election in massachusetts it was on the
order about 442 dollars per person per
year in the individual health insurance
market and that adds up to about 93
million overall it's not an
apples-to-apples comparison but the
initial cost of massachusetts health
reform was around 800 million dollars
for the first year and so we're getting
welfare gains from the um
from the uh
the reduction in adverse election due to
the individual mandate that are
certainly still relatively large
relative to what the state spent
so just to conclude we've gone through
uh through research on from four
different papers on what happened and
under massachusetts health reform and
let's just step back and think about
what does that imply for the for
connecticut and for the affordable care
act so first we examined what happened
to hospital and preventive care we saw
that length of stay decreased admissions
from the emergency room decreased and
that hospital costs remained on the same
trajectory then we examined what
happened to the labor market we saw that
there was an increase in
employer-sponsored health insurance
coverage no big aggregate impacts on the
labor market but for those people that
took up health insurance on their
employers they did see wage decreases
which are consistent with them valuing
the health insurance that they receive
through their employers on about 75
cents on the dollar
and then finally when we examined what
happened to the individual health
insurance market we saw that there was
indeed adverse election in the
individual health insurance market
before the reform which means that
healthy people were not purchasing
coverage at an affordable price and we
definitely saw that mitigated from
before the reform to after the reform
because we saw that coverage increased
dramatically and premiums and insurer
costs went down
i welcome any questions great
so
we're gonna
we're gonna get some questions from you
guys i wanted to follow up on that so
so quality went up
premiums went down
the labor market wasn't really affected
it sounds pretty good what was what were
the terrible things that happened
so i i want to emphasize that entering
into this research we had no agenda to
show that massachusetts health reform
was was uh going to do something good i
will say that the weight of the evidence
here looks fairly positive but i think
the big thing that's really left out
from this picture is not what happened
to hospital costs but what happened to
the cost of the state government and to
the individuals that were purchasing
health insurance in the state and i
think that remains a major issue in the
state of massachusetts so there have
been several other pieces of legislation
focused on cost control and i think that
the reform doesn't seem to have
necessarily exacerbated the cost control
problem but there was a big existing
cost control problem in massachusetts as
there is in all of the other states and
that's really the negative aspect of
massachusetts health reform and one that
the state is still struggling with so
essentially it expanded access but it
didn't really address the cost issue
exactly
so
yesterday i was on the phone with a
journalist who said you know what does
this mean for the folks who aren't
getting coverage through the exchanges
you know what huge changes are they
going to see and i i had my answer but
i'm curious
so you and i are employer insured
through yale
is the world going to look radically
different in
seven months time
um
i don't really think so i mean i think
that you're going to see small if you
already have your employer insurance and
the employer doesn't decide to change
that insurance
you're going to see
small things like the kinds of things
that i mentioned like certain things
being covered that weren't before
like vaccines um
but i don't think you're going to see
i don't think you're going to see a
major difference unless
employer you're part of some kind of
employment conglomerate where the
employers are incentivized to add more
workers they hadn't had it before right
like so if your employer's incentives
don't change the same population stays
employed um i don't think so i'd be
curious if you think as an economist
that there would be you would see some
differences but uh i think obama has
been saying before that if you got your
employer insurance on the employer is
going to stay the same and i think
that's by and large
the one area of the market where things
are going to be the same i will say this
that um
there are
no i'll stop there
i mean that was that was my take the the
i don't think we're going to see the
world look radically different you know
that it really is a tremendous expansion
for the folks who didn't have insurance
before but for the rest of us i don't
think the world is going to look
radically different i guess to put you
on the spot with a political question
why do you think then we see such a
stark you know if you looked at
the echo chamber in washington you would
think that the world was about dent that
health care was going to change as we
know it okay so let me make two comments
one point one small like sort of
addendum to what you just said is i do
think that if you're somebody who bought
your insurance before not through an
employer but now is eligible for
subsidies your world could change
because you are going to be getting
significant help from the federal
government to buy your own insurance i
think for those of us in the employer
markets that's the market that's really
going to stay the same i think there are
differences for people in the individual
market but very positive but federal
dollar help differences i think as a
political matter um i think most people
in the room know uh ever since ronald
reagan
had his famous advertisement before he
was the governor of california ronald
reagan against socialized medicine right
there has been a uh atmosphere in this
country a political atmosphere uh that
anything anything any radical changes to
our health performances our health care
system that involve government
intervention in this system is some how
putting our country on the road to
socialism right now it's sort of a
ridiculous thing everybody recognizes
that we already had a government
subsidized system the employer provided
health insurance system is subsidized by
tax credits from the federal government
right so the current private employer
subsidized health insurance system that
we have it's not actually a private
system we already had some elements of
federal intervention but
everyone knows that health care has been
something of a third bail of politics
everyone who lived through the clinton
efforts in the 1990s knows that and in
particular i would say this time around
the individual mandate sparked a lot of
concerns the idea that the government
could tell you to do something uh really
touched at sort of the libertarian and
capitalistic traditions of our country i
will note that the individual mandate
was originally
an idea that was proposed by republicans
and not democrats a number of years ago
so it does have bipartisan a bipartisan
history of support
but the idea the federal government can
actually tell you to do something i
think sparked panic
in the hearts of a lot of people
so so looking at massachusetts
what would you do to improve what they
did you know if you could if you could
change one thing that they did or
improve the way the the aca is
structured now
what do you think it would be
so i think i think i'll answer with
respect to the affordable care act as
opposed to in massachusetts because as
i've mentioned i think one of the
biggest issues that's that's not being
addressed as much as i would like it to
be addressed is cost control and i think
one thing that's that's really not
touched in the affordable care act is
getting rid of the tax advantage for
employer-sponsored health insurance and
i think part of that is politically that
that would perhaps erode the incentive
for people to get health insurance
through their employers and the
incentives in the reform are to allow
people who have employer sponsored
health insurance coverage to keep that
coverage but we spend about 116 billion
dollars per year by not collecting taxes
on employer-sponsored health insurance
that's actually the largest tax
expenditure of the federal government
and that's actually
one big area that's just not touched
almost at all by the affordable care act
there is going to be the introduction of
a new cadillac tax for health insurance
plans over a certain amount of money and
that will bind more and more over time
to the extent that in the long run some
of us might actually see
an impact of the cadillac tax but i
think one big thing that i would like to
would have liked to see is to
rid us of the exclusion for
employer-sponsored health insurance
particularly because i think it
encourages health insurance that is in
many ways too generous
and that's escalating the cost problem
fantastic so we're now going to go out
and ask your questions so this was
you know how do the exchanges work just
just explain what these exchanges are i
mean so a lot of the terms in healthcare
are bending the cost curve i didn't know
the curves
how do you bend a curve what is this
what is a health exchange and how does
it work
do you would you like to take this one i
mean so i think the answer to this is
that we're going to have this next panel
we're going to talk about how it's going
to work specifically in connecticut and
they're going to be designed differently
in every state so i think that you can
add or men detract from that i the
reason i like to think about it like
expedia is that it's supposed to be uh
you can do it in person too if you're
not a computer person but the idea is
supposed to be that you should be able
to go online to your state's exchange or
the federal exchange operated in your
state and you're supposed to be able to
look compare health plans side by side
and see what's covered the federal
government has different levels of plans
they're bronze gold platinum and you
know which is better right the platinum
cam plan covers more we have to pay a
larger deductible the bronze plan is
sort of the basic there's a benchmark
plan so the plans all meet the plans
that are on the exchanges all meet a
minimum level of quality and cover
essential health benefits that they have
been defined um and the idea is that
you're supposed to be able to go on and
see let's say i want to be in a bronze
plan here are three bronze plans that
are that are my state has told me are
basically equivalent but one
maybe covers
um
a certain kind of drug
that i take
and another one doesn't so for me
blonde's bronze plan number one would be
the better plan because i take a lot of
that particular drug i think uh that's
sort of the best way to describe it i do
think that would you add to a different
yeah i think that sounds like that
sounds like exactly what's going to
happen so you'll be able to go on to a
web page compare plans sign up online
and and have insurance coverage or you
can go in in person if you'd and and
write and sign up on paper um or i think
you can also do it by my mail
so
there's a question here about job lock
this question of so so one of the big
issues in the us right now is that we
because we get our
insurance through our employer we might
be less likely to change jobs and so the
question for you is you know it was job
lock an issue in massachusetts did that
change can we expect it to change
i think that's a really good question i
would have expected job lock to change
because uh what is job so so job block
is the phenomenon whereby people are
afraid to leave their jobs because
they'll lose their health insurance
and you would think that the incentives
under under the massachusetts health
reform and the affordable care act would
lead to a decrease in job lock because
now perhaps individuals can go get
affordable coverage on the exchange and
then they'll they'll be more likely to
become entrepreneurs or be self-employed
or even just switch from one job or to
another and perhaps have a gap in
coverage
we actually did examine that in our
paper and we didn't find a decrease in
job lock which i think is very
surprising there's there's also a paper
by brad heim and etai lurie where they
examine the tax records in massachusetts
relative to other states and they see if
the propensity to be self-employed
changed differentially in massachusetts
relative to other states from before the
reform to after the reform and i would
have expected that you would see an
increase in self-employment and that's
not indeed what they see so i don't know
if that's something that will happen
over time or if it was just that the
incentives weren't necessarily there i
think it'll be interesting to see if
those findings generalize to the
affordable care act fantastic so this
next question is actually a perfect
segue to jacob's panel so it's asking
you know if it costs around ten thousand
dollars for a company to insure an
employee but they only pay a 2000
penalty if they don't do it are these
incentives aligned correctly and and i
think with that we'll we'll transfer
over to this panel which is going to
look at what the aca means for you guys
genuinely what's going to change
so thanks thanks
all right
all right
thanks
you don't have to drink out of sex
that would be a secretary
yeah
our health care benefits exactly
okay so
we're
moving into the second panel i have a
few preferatory announcements um the
first is it was one of the questions i
received was whether or not we would
make the powerpoints available from the
talks and the answer is yes if the
if the speakers make them available to
us and i expect most of them will and
we'll make them we'll put them up on the
website after the event
and those of you who've registered we
you as you know we have your email
addresses so we'll send a notice that
that material is available a second um
we'll be
handing out the cards this time right at
the beginning and while the presentation
is going you can write down uh your
responses your your questions um and i
should just say that obviously we didn't
get to a lot of the cards on the last
panel um so i have them all here and a
number of them really pertain more to
the discussion we're going to have now
so
i'm looking forward to so if you've
asked a question for example
about
what kinds of coverage
people can get within the exchange you
don't have to ask it again i have i have
that information here
so i'm going to be very brief in
introducing our
our panelists even though they both have
very impressive and long backgrounds um
i yesterday i just went on and made sure
that i i knew uh about the the work that
uh the panelists had done and and find
out and found out that diane roland uh
our first speaker is an urban fantasy
writer and is best known for her white
trash zombie series um this is the the
perils of google it turns out that is
diana rowland have you heard this one
before okay um so diane is of course not
um although that would be a very
interesting health policy um paper she's
not an author of that series she's the
executive vice president of the henry j
kaiser family foundation as well as the
executive director of the kaiser
commission on medicaid and the uninsured
if you do not know about the kaiser
family foundation it's an it's an
amazing resource and you should
definitely visit their website
she's also
an adjunct professor in the department
of health policy management at the
bloomberg school of public health of the
johns hopkins university and i would
just mention
that diane has
been an enormous
enormously important policy expert
especially around issues surrounding
medicaid for for many years and she's
going to provide us i think with a
really great insight into how both
medicaid and the exchanges will affect
access to coverage for individuals
within connecticut um and our second
panelist is heather mead heather is
coming from i didn't find a funny
alternative heather mead out there she's
coming from ernst young's washington
council practice but she's also
worked within government she worked she
was the deputy director of surrogate
scheduling at the dnc she worked for
senator patter patty murray as well as
the transition staff of senator maria
cantwell so she brings both uh
insights from ersten young which is of
course an expert on employers role
as well as her own policy experience
within government and with that i will
open things up to diane
well i'm extremely pleased to be here um
because coming to connecticut is coming
home for me i was born and raised here i
haven't been
here in a long time but always enjoy
being back in a state that is a leading
state as i said when i was asked to talk
on this panel
most of the time i've been talking about
those states that decided not to go
forward with their own state-based
exchange not to go forward with the
medicaid expansion so it's a really a
delight to be in connecticut which is a
progressive state as always
what i wanted to start with today though
was to remind us
about really why we have the affordable
care act and that's that we do and still
do have nearly 50 million americans who
go without health insurance coverage and
some of the elements that help design
the act are that many of them are
attached to the workforce but don't get
coverage through their employer most of
them in low-wage jobs which is why
family income of the uninsured is so low
and many of them are adults without
dependent children or parents of
children because we've made great
progress both in connecticut and over
the other states in the country and
extending more coverage to children but
we've often left adults behind so i like
to say that the goal of health reform
was to finally give some people over age
18 some of the kinds of options we've
given to children
and what you see is that insurance
matters everyone talks about it really
just as a cost but for families it
matters on how they get their care where
they get their care whether they
postpone care whether they end up
sickering in our emergency rooms and in
our hospitals eating up more of our
health care dollars because they could
have been treated outpatient and with
primary care so the second goal of
course of the health reform legislation
is to connect people to care earlier to
remove some of the cost-sharing barriers
on preventive services and to really get
better access to primary care
so with that you'll see the
the familiar we call this the kaiser
triangle um i liked seeing it earlier
from abby but it really is that we were
trying in health reform to put
back pieces of our health system and i
think everyone agrees that we could have
done it in a more simpler way if we did
medicare for all which was one of the
options on the table but politically
that was not going to happen
so in fact the romney approach was
adopted as the national approach
and it really does do very little to
change employer-sponsored coverage other
than to provide some preventive services
and some other incentives there it
really is all about trying to connect
uninsured people to the health care
system to make it affordable and to make
coverage available
and you see here in this slide that the
18 of our population that's uninsured
a majority of them are very low income
those are individuals for whom medicaid
was intended to be the expansion vehicle
across all states those in the kind of
orange color
fell in the income area between 139
of poverty and 400 of poverty which is
about 90 000 for a family of four and
that group was intended to be able to if
they were uninsured and not covered
through their employer be able to gain
better individual health insurance
coverage through a reformed health care
marketplace it started being called an
exchange and we've renamed it
marketplace since apparently the word
exchange doesn't translate well into
spanish which is a big issue in many of
the states and then for those who were
above the 400 percent of poverty to
allow them to still have access to
better coverage through the individual
insurance market but those would be
without subsidies
and the second goal was to make sure
that this was an easy way for people to
get their coverage whether they could do
it through the telephone by mail by
coverage we call this really also the no
wrong door policy that rather you're
eligible for medicaid and and got that
kind of coverage or whether you're going
into the exchange you could apply in one
place you could apply in one single
application and then you would be
processed with some income verification
to see where you were eligible and that
this was a real time eligibility
determination you didn't have to wait
two months to have your application
processed it could be processed quickly
and you could then select and put in the
kind of insurance coverage you want
and to try and make the
affordability of care for the lowest
income population that was going to be
eligible for medicaid less of a burden
on the states the federal government
agreed in the first three years to pick
up 100 percent of the cost of the
expansion of medicaid and then phase
that down over time to where the federal
government would pay 90 percent of the
cost of the state's 10. and as you've
heard before many of the states
especially those with republican
governors who had sued to stop the
implementation of the affordable care
act have elected not to do the medicaid
expansion i would note sadly that those
are the states with the very lowest
income eligibility like at 17 percent of
poverty for parents and no coverage for
childless adults in their states so many
of the uninsured that i showed you in
the beginning
will be left uninsured as a result of
the state decisions not to expand
coverage especially people under 100 of
poverty but that's not the case in
connecticut so connecticut should gain
both federal dollars to help provide the
coverage for their medicaid expansion
population contributing hopefully to a
substantial reduction in the number of
low-income uninsured people here to
increase revenue for the providers so
that care that has been uncompensated
will be converted into insurance paid
care
decreased and uncompensated care costs
for the states and also savings to many
of the state-funded programs like your
mental health programs and others that
will now be included in the medicaid
expansion coverage and finally we know
that health care is a big part of every
economy and so i think there are
economic effects that you can expect in
terms of increased jobs and increased
revenues to the state
so what does health reform really mean
for the state of connecticut it means
expanding medicaid coverage to
individuals with incomes of up to 138
the federal poverty level about sixteen
thousand dollars for a single individual
it means the creation of state
based run by the state instead of the
federal opt
health insurance marketplaces you're
going to hear more about this i know at
lunch but access health connecticut is
going to be your major
marketplace for individuals looking for
self-purchase coverage in the individual
market and they'll be regional
navigators who will try and conduct
outreach and manage over 300 assisters
who will help people to gain the
information they need to make the wise
selections that we hope they'll be
making about their health care coverage
and how that will divide up is that uh
in the nation you see the distribution
here
of the people under 138 of poverty that
will qualify for medicaid among the
uninsured is about
50
in connecticut you have a slightly lower
level of individuals among your
uninsured who fall in that income
bracket but it's still about 42 percent
of the uninsured in connecticut should
qualify for the medicaid expansion
another 41 percent of the uninsured
would come in to be available to go into
the health insurance marketplace and to
gain subsidies to help pay for their
coverage and then a smaller share those
above 400 percent the federal poverty
level or 90 000 for a family of four
would be still eligible to come in and
get coverage through the marketplace but
they would have no availability of
federal subsidies to help offset the
cost
so i like to have at least one pretty
infographic in every presentation and i
really would love to see the ones that
were shown earlier
incorporated into more but this is just
a picture to show you sort of what the
medicaid umbrella does under healthcare
reform and the fact that for the first
time childless adults who were not part
of our elizabethan poor laws and
therefore were historically left out of
medicaid and could not states who
covered them could not get federal
matching funds for them are finally
fully eligible so what changes about
medicaid nationally is that it now is a
program that's income related and not no
longer a categorical program except in
those states that have elected not to
proceed
and the difference though and why
connecticut is is such a leader is that
you can see here where the eligibility
levels are for children and for adults
across the country and you can see where
connecticut has been so connecticut had
been one of the first states to even
take up the option to broaden coverage
under medicaid to childless adults as
soon as the law passed in 2010 so you've
already got all the coverage categories
there and what health reform will do in
january is raise those income
eligibility levels and provide fuller
federal financing for that care
the second thing of course about
connecticut is that you are implementing
a state-based exchange and in that
exchange you will have we've we've got a
report out that shows some of the plans
that will be offered there'll be
different rating areas across
the state one of the changes is that
pre-existing conditions cannot be an
exclusionary factor and one that i
particularly like is that they can no
longer differentiate in rates between
women and men so that there's no more
gender rating in the private market but
they have allowed in these markets
within their bands to have age-related
bands so that different individuals at
different age levels because of our
differences in our healthcare
utilization will have premiums that pay
more but the major reforms here are that
the benefits are also
very different in terms of the offering
through the exchange marketplace they
have include more mental health services
they include more
of the maternity care which has
historically been left out of most of
the individual market plans without a
special rider they have standards for
what can be covered and so the benefit
package that individuals are getting
when they buy their coverage through
these new market pla places is very
different from what they would have
bought five or ten years ago on the
individual market so it's very hard to
do apples to oranges comparisons and
that's what you would have between the
two but these are the basic monthly
costs in the hartford rating area
and then what you see in this next slide
is what happens with these market costs
to individuals in these different age
groups so that they
can really see the reduction in their
cost due to the
ability to get a subsidy from the
federal government
so i'll close by just saying that i
think that the affordable care act will
mean a great deal to the residents of
connecticut it's a historic opportunity
to fill long-standing gaps connecticut's
a great state and i'm sure as it
launches
on october 1st and then implements the
coverage on january 1st it'll be one of
those states that we're looking at to
say this is how it's done right so good
luck and congratulations on being such
an outstanding state thank you
all right uh now we have heather and i
just want to note that we have uh
i think
these aren't locusts but we're running
10 minutes behind with lunch so we're
gonna have a little more time for
questions which is excellent and heather
i'm looking forward to hearing from you
thank you and it is i do have to say it
usually i i speak to employers about the
affordable care act and um so the
willingness of this group to stay here
and listen and participate is a little
unusual for me and it's a more welcome
audience than i'm used to speaking to so
i really have to thank yale university
and senator murphy for putting this
event together
my topic today is just a little bit
different than um let's see here
uh
some of the other professions i am not
talking about the law from the
individual perspective i've been asked
to talk about the affordable care act
from the perspective of a small employer
and from employers
and
there's been a lot about this in the
news so hopefully we can talk a little
bit about some of the implications and
why we may be seeing what we're seeing
and i think it's important to remember
when we look at the affordable care act
that
this isn't just about exchanges um the
cornerstone of our health care system
and of the affordable care act remains
the employer-sponsored healthcare system
while there were many new ideas debated
at the end of the day we stuck with what
we knew best and it happens that 149
million americans in 2013 are receiving
their health care coverage through their
employer this is about 58
of non-elderly americans we expect this
number to change the same i'm stealing
numbers straight from diane from kaiser
and they do it's a fabulous website and
i highly recommend it to you
and about 70 of americans have access to
coverage um so this tells us that the
success of the aca is really going to
hinge on the success of the employer
market and employers staying in the game
and continuing to offer coverage and in
large part that's what we're seeing
we're not seeing large numbers of
employers announcing that they're
dropping and running to the doors and
there are a lot of good reasons for that
but we are going to see some changes in
the trends and what employers are
offering and i think it's helpful to
understand what it is in the aca that is
driving some of those changes and what
you may be seeing in your own health
care packages
so
in as we discussed this
you know one of the comparisons that i
like to talk about about why
employer-sponsored healthcare remains so
important is because we have 149 million
americans in employer-sponsored coverage
now um that doesn't say anything about
you know the quality of that coverage or
how helpful it is to them but when we
talk about the exchanges we're really
talking about in 2013 seven million in
new individuals enrolling the government
has put out saying they're hoping by
march they're going to enroll seven
million individuals into these exchanges
so when we're looking you know
what's happening in healthcare we need
to look not just at the exchange
experience but also what's happening in
employer sponsored health care coverage
99 percent of large employers with 200
or more employees offer health care
coverage now
they do it the affordable care act was
not about changing uh necessarily the
employer or fixing i guess it's the
right word fixing the employer sponsored
system we were addressing a lot of the
problems that were happening in the
individual market we were addressing a
lot of problems in the small employer
market so when you move to the
employer small market um between three
to 200 or so that number drops off
precipitously and only about 50 percent
of small employers under 200 employees
actually offer health care coverage to
their employees today and there are some
good reasons for that on the part of
employers and what they say is cost you
know we mentioned that cost continues to
be a real issue and not just for
individuals but also for employers
someone has to pay the other portion of
the premium
on average large employers pay 81 of the
81 of the total premium for individuals
and about 69 of the cost for a family so
when we look at what we pay as
individuals for that coverage there's
another really big piece of that cost
out there that employers are shouldering
and so all of the cost changes are
really affecting employers as well as
they're affecting individuals and these
are driving some of the changes that
we're hearing about in the media and
that we're seeing in our own health
plans
so when they went just looked at the
small employer market um the law that we
have is not a straight player pay it's
not it's it's dissimilar to
massachusetts in some really key ways
one is is that the law doesn't say you
have to offer coverage or pay a penalty
what it says is if you're a small
employer that's any employer with fewer
than 50 full-time equivalent employees
so that's going to add up your full-time
employees that are now working 30 hours
per week or more it's going to add up
your part-time employees so if you're a
small employer under these definitions
um our employer mandate isn't going to
apply to you
if you're a large employer
we're going to put a free rider
provision on you because we think that
you should be offering healthcare
coverage to your individuals and
everyone else is tired of tired of
shouldering the costs of your
uncompensated care so if you're not
offering coverage you're going to have
to pay a penalty and if you're offering
coverage that's not substantial enough
to help your employees avoid healthcare
costs we're going to hit you with a
smaller penalty so it's more of a free
rider than a player play so when i think
when we look at some of the economic
impacts and what the incentives are for
employers we have to remember that it's
not an apples to apples between
massachusetts and our affordable care
act experiment
we looked at the small group market we
said look the reason that they're not
offering coverage here is because we
have some problems that need to be
addressed and the affordable care
act did some things to address these
problems the first thing it did was it
said
we need some market changes and so they
changed the way that
insurers i think as was mentioned
previously can rate coverage in the
small group market as well as the
individual market
so it disallowed insurers from rating
and
raising costs for
small businesses that have fewer
employees that can't spread costs across
the their populations and so they
prohibited health-based rating in the
small employer market
um this is good for small employers um
across the board but if you were a small
employer that maybe um was a technology
company that only hired uh 25 year old
men that never went to the doctor you
may see health cost increases whereas if
you were a small employer that hired
social workers that tended to be
you know older women
you may be seeing significant cost
decreases so the across the board
the employer experience will be
different for these small employers as
they go to look for new premiums
the other thing we know about small
employers is they're really interested
in doing their jobs they're not
particularly interested in administering
health care plans they're not really
interested in health policy as
interested as all of you are they are
really not interested in this session in
fact when i was asked to come talk the i
was you know told why don't you just go
through the provisions and we'll help
some of our small connecticut employers
understand what they need to do turns
out they're all busy doing their jobs
today and so we're just talking about
some of the general things that apply to
small employers rather than walking
through the tedious details of how
it applies to employers
so to help with this particular problem
the affordable care act creates what are
called shop exchanges these are small
business health option plans these are
special marketplaces for these small
employers where they can go the state
has taken on that burden and in
connecticut you have a state-based shop
shop program where the state takes on
that burden of negotiating with
employers it comes up with these plans
it will do the premium negotiations
employers still have the ability to
choose between plans for their employees
and that shop exchange will take off
that administrative burden it will send
the checks to the insurers it will
communicate with employees and it will
sort of try to
play that market role that a large
employer is able to do by
acting as an aggregator for all of the
small employers
the other thing we do is we offer a new
small employer tax credit the small
employer tax credit is available for
small employers i'm not using my slides
because i'm just talking
is available for small employers with
up to 25 full-time employees but you
have to have an average annual wage of
50 000 or less the tax credit is only
available to employers who enroll
through these shop exchanges this is in
order to get that population up in those
shop exchanges
and
it is uh a sliding scale so if you
happen to be a small employer that is
watching this um later on at night when
it's since it's streaming live and being
recorded there are excellent resources
available on the irs website where you
can go you can put in your average wages
you can put in some demographic
information about your small business
to find out whether or not you might be
eligible to reduce the cost of coverage
for your
for your employees and for you as an
employer and it's up to 50 of the cost
of the coverage that is offered
so with all of these great new changes
why are employers still complaining it
seems like we've done a lot to help
these problems that we seem to hear in
the media a lot of complaints from
employers
and um
i think there are some good reasons for
that i think the first one that we
discussed is cost
cost uh remains an issue um another
issue that employers are dealing with is
a loss of flexibility a lot of the
market rules that have been implemented
have decreased the options for employers
to
save on costs and to design their plans
in flexible ways that they were
previously
that are driving some accelerations in
the marketplace that we're seeing and
how plans are being designed now
and
even for those employers that are small
employers that don't have any employer
mandate on them
there are still some obligatory things
that they have to do
as part of the communication effort to
individuals all employers that are
subject to the fair labor standards act
are as of october 1st required to give
all of their employees a notice
that tells them exchanges are available
and this is what i'm offering or not
offering to you as an employer
and there are also um going to be
involved in the affordable care act
system whether they want to or not when
individuals go to the exchange and they
apply for a tax credit the
exchange itself will have the ability to
ping employers and say hey is heather
mead really your employee she showed up
here she asked for a credit and
employers are going to need to have a
system in place where they can
communicate back to the exchange and say
yes
i hired heather no i've never ever heard
of her i think she's some vampire novel
writer i don't know who she is
so whether or not you want to be
involved as a small employer you will be
involved there's also the opportunity
that when i talk to employer groups i
think is really important to think about
from the individual perspective under
the affordable care act there is a
clawback provision
if an individual goes to the exchange
and they get a tax credit and at the end
of the year the irs says hey guess what
individual
your income changed during the year you
were no longer eligible for that tax
credit
the irs is required to claw back that
tax credit which will leave a number of
lower income individuals facing
hefty tax penalties at the end of the
year
if you are an employer with low income
employees this is a bad situation for
you to be in and it's a bad situation
for your employees
under the law there's an opportunity and
it's optional you don't have to do it
but the when your employee receives a
tax penalty even if you're a small
employer the ir or the state exchange in
your state will come back and say hey
employer your employee got a tax credit
you can do nothing or you have 90 days
to appeal that notification if you're an
employer that offers
that offers insurance and you know
they're not eligible for it you can go
back and say hey exchange i know my
individual here did try to enroll
they're not eligible they should come
back and be in my plan instead this will
prevent those individuals from receiving
erroneous tax credits which will save
them from clawbacks at the end of the
year so even if you're a small employer
that's throwing up your hand saying i
want nothing to do with obamacare there
are a lot of things in the law that you
should learn about and think about just
from an employee communication
perspective that will be really
important moving forward
and
just a note on i know we've seen a lot
of this in the news that i do want to
talk about um sort of the line in the
sand the affordable care act draws lines
in the sand that the massachusetts um
plan did not
uh the two big ones we hear about 50
employers that are capping their
workforces that can't grow my small
business
because i don't want to be subject to
obamacare which kicks in at 50. or the
other one is dropping employees hours to
under 28 hours and um you know i think
the economic data that we looked at
tells the story in some ways but not in
other ways um this applies to a very
small you know the number of employers
that are right at that 50 line it's not
a huge portion of our employer workforce
the number of employees that are
part-time it's about 19 of our overall
workforce so while we look at the big
economic trends true the employer
sponsor system is moving forward
employers are not dropping coverage in
droves they are continuing to want to
offer voluntary benefits to their
employees for the same reasons they did
before because they want healthy
workforces and they want strong employee
retention but there is there are new
lines in the sand and there are a number
of employers that will be
moving their workforces to respond to
those lines because there are cost
considerations for those employers
um so for i think the one that will be
really interesting to watch as we move
forward
is what happens in that part-time
workforce with a definition of 30 hours
i work with a lot of smaller employers
and while we don't see large trends with
large employers we are seeing a large
number of small employers that are
making small changes to their workforce
and how they define full-time employee
versus part-time employee and this is
important when it becomes the cost
because for these employers where this
line is drawn
the healthcare dollar for employers is
finite also and so we're asking these
employers to stretch their finite dollar
over a larger number of employees and so
this is driving some of the acceleration
and benefit changes that we're seeing
one of these is an increase in
deductibles so you now see about 50
percent 58 i think of small employer
plans have a deductible of a thousand
dollars or more
this is a lot of out-of-pocket costs for
individuals and i think this is a trend
that will be accelerated by some of the
rating rules and by some of the market
changes that are in the affordable care
act so this is one of the things that
we're seeing that you may see as an
individual would be a trend to high
high deductible health plans
greater out of pocket costs for high
for deductibles and cost sharing
a continued focus on areas where
employers have the flexibility to
control costs these are wellness
programs
implementing waiting periods
and so some of these things that look a
little
consumer unfriendly but are there
because they're the ways that employers
are still able to control costs under
the law so as we think about how this
affects employers and how it affects
individuals
i think it's one thing is that this is
not necessarily creating new trends but
it is accelerating some of the
previously existing trends that we were
seeing
in the employer sponsored market so
thank you very much thank you heather
okay well i have a lot of questions to
ask and there and i'm gonna stick to
your questions um and try to bring as
many of them together as i can so diane
the first question that comes up a lot
is about
both documented and undocumented
immigrants and
coverage under the affordable care act
so could you explain the situation
for immigrants of both types and also
their families as well as um
this was one question here which is
whether or not
undocumented
immigrants might actually some
one of the questions has to be
advantaged insofar as they are not
subject to the requirements and there
are ways to get care that
absent insurance so
go ahead
well the affordable care act basically
did not cover undocumented immigrants
nor does the medicaid program there
specifically prohibited from medicaid
coverage except in the case of needing
emergency care where if they show up at
a hospital the hospital can get some
compensation for their care
there is also for legal immigrants a
five-year ban on eligibility within the
medicaid program
so for the first five years that a legal
immigrant is here they are ineligible
for medicaid coverage
but the law
the affordable care act does allow that
individual to if they qualify go into
the exchange and get coverage during
that five-year waiting period in the
exchange so there is for legal
immigrants within the five-year waiting
period some ability um at cost though
they have to pay the cost of going into
the exchange
they're not eligible for tax subsidies
in other words they're not eligible for
the taxes and
they're not eligible if their income is
below 100 of the poverty line right well
no one below 100 the poverty level is
eligible for coverage in the exchange
which is the glitch that leaves in a
state that doesn't expand so many people
out
there's attempts in some of the states
new york for example the neighboring
state requires that immigrants
be covered and so they cover them but
they do that with state dollars instead
of with the federal dollars right well
heather you started to bring this up so
you
can you explain a little bit more
specifically what the incentives are
around part-time versus full-time work
and
why it is a lot of people ask this
question why it is that you don't expect
a lot of employers to
to drop coverage even as you expect some
moves away from more generous coverage
sure so
the first question is um
about
why these numbers so the affordable care
act has an employer mandate or shared
responsibility provision that applies to
large employers
and there are two penalties and the the
first penalty is the free rider
provision and it says that if you don't
offer coverage to your
full-time employees and their dependents
their child dependence then you face a
tax penalty of two thousand dollars
times your total number of full-time
employees so that definition has a lot
of emphasis on who your full-time
employees are so that number really
starts to matter
and the law has a new definition of
full-time employee which is anyone who
is working on average in any month 30
hours per week per month so it's a
monthly determination of whether or not
an individual is a full-time employee if
employers aren't offering coverage to
that individual for that month that tax
penalty kicks in so there's really a new
focus on
who are my full-time employees and am i
offering them coverage
because otherwise there will be tax
penalties so this is a new definition
for employers we previously did not have
a federal definition of who a full-time
employee was so we care a lot more about
that now
for large employers you know that 99
that was already offering coverage
they were doing so on a voluntary basis
our employer sponsored system has always
been voluntary in some ways this is the
first time that we're moving to a
partially non-voluntary system employers
still aren't required to offer coverage
um but there are some stronger
incentives for doing so
but employers have always had um a want
to be in the game because one they have
um they can it's a competitive advantage
you are providing coverage they can
attract and retain better employees a
healthy workforce is a productive
workforce and employers right now have a
lot of control over the benefits and can
tailor them to their own workforce um
you know i think it was mentioned that
it took us 10 years to address health
care reform again it's going to take us
at least another 10 years to address it
again based on where we are with our
political process
and
during that time period employers uh you
know we've got the employer-sponsored
system and as they watch this unfold
there isn't another option for them
right now or another place for them to
go i think it's really important to note
that if you have employer sponsored
coverage or an offer of it you're not
eligible for a tax credit so individuals
aren't going to be able to go out and
shop around to see whether or not they
want an exchange credit or their
employer plan
and so employers have an incentive to
offer good good plans to their employees
if they want to retain them
so
diane
one one thing that you you put up there
was the terms of coverage um
and
i have a sort of quick two-part question
the first part is just you know what are
the core areas where coverage has been
really anemic in the past say mental
health or dental coverage that that it's
changing now and then second um what
what does
that generosity of coverage as you were
saying imply about um the sort of
relative premiums we should expect um we
now know what they are between current
individual insurance if you will and the
kind of coverage people would be
purchasing through the exchanges
well certainly one of the biggest
exclusions from coverage in the
individual market was pre-existing
conditions and since the pre-existing
conditions can no longer
be excluded it means that for any set of
health challenges you have your coverage
in the exchange ought to be
able to cover it without excluding those
benefits and then they added in some of
the more traditional benefits the
essential benefits that we consider part
of most employer-based insurance the
largest uh item being of course
maternity care but also including some
additional mental health benefits for
better parity and also
some pediatric dental benefits but we
didn't they didn't go full
scale on the dental side
what that means is that the coverage is
more comprehensive and also because of
the changes in
the rating so that they can no longer
rate women higher they can no longer
exclude pre-existing conditions you're
going to see at different age groups
some increase costs so if i was 25 and
buying insurance before in the
individual market i'm going to be paying
more now for it although there are some
exceptions for young individuals to just
get catastrophic coverage and if i'm 50
years old i'm going to be paying a
lesser premium than i probably would
have before and have broader coverage so
it really does sort of sort out by kind
of who you were before and who you are
today
so coming back heather to something that
you brought up i wouldn't have asked it
if you hadn't which is the fact that
there are many small employers concerned
about the law
let's talk i mean you have a background
in uh public policy and politics a
little bit about the the political uh
realities um and um obviously
connecticut is distinctive in that
there's broad support we know that
massachusetts amanda was talking about
was not was not just
did not just increase experience and
increase in coverage there's also fairly
high levels of support at the national
level right now there's both
a lot of ignorance about the details of
a lot and let's let's face it a lot of
opposition
and so i'm wondering how you expect that
to play out in particular what role were
some of the other stakeholders
that
including employers will play in this
process insurers employers physicians
providers um you know what's
if you're optimistic as you seem to be
about the law taking root um what's what
do you think is going to be driving that
i i you know there really aren't a lot
of political options to repeal the law
the political realities are that this
this lies is moving forward and for
employers and providers um that are
going to be in the game regardless of
their personal opinions about the law um
you know
there are strong incentives as we move
into 2014 to become part of the more
productive political process and making
changes that they think are valuable uh
to them and the law moving forward so i
i think that at some point we will
move past the transition relief on the
employer mandate and uh employers will
begin to folk you know focus more on on
what's in it for them
well i should notice that that yeah
sorry add a little comment most pieces
of legislation of this magnitude also
have what we call technical corrections
that go in and really fix
the pieces that either slip through in
the middle of the night or that they now
know don't work as they try to write the
regulations and the political
environment and the repeal
constant votes have meant that a lot of
what could have been fixed and
simplified
in the normal process over the last two
years never happened and so i think what
we're going to see going forward is that
there'll be glitches
and they'll be recorded as disasters but
they really will be pointing toward how
to fix it and keep it going and i think
if you if you look at the dialogue that
larger employers are having now it's
it's not about repealing the law it's
about specific changes that they would
like to see to the act diane what do you
see as the two most serious problems
with the law right now that could be
could have been fixed in a more
productive political environment well
one is the the penalty that um
individuals would have to pay if their
income was was not adjusted properly and
if they had income changes and they've
tried to figure out how to do more of
that within the law and i think the
other one is really just
some of the data interfaces that they
need to make the program work
and i'd of course like to fix it by
saying all states have to do it
well obviously there's one
technical big change that happened which
was due to the supreme court's
intervention
and
so that's obviously a third area that
was unexpected that you would have this
question of whether the states would
move forward on medicaid um so i'm and
you said uh and abby beforehand
said that there's a you know that this
this there's that there will be more
pressure in that direction given how
much money is on the table also
providers providing uncompensated care
um are going to not be getting right
disproportionate share payments right
that compensate them so that there's
there's a economic
there'll be a political pressure perhaps
from providers as well but in addition i
think it's also important to understand
that even in a state that chooses not to
expand
the supreme court didn't strike down all
the other provisions of the law so that
they are actively changing their
enrollment procedures their medicaid
eligibility will be determined by the
new rules so the decision to expand will
be much less of a uphill fight because
much of the i.t capacity will be there
and the exchanges will be operating so
we may see them come come forward in the
next year or two well we have just time
for a couple more quick questions
heather
you brought up uh changes that have
occurred one that i'll mention and i
don't you don't necessarily need to
elaborate on is this move towards
private exchanges where employers are
actually
providing a
something like a defined contribution
benefit where they give a fixed amount
and the individual then shops on a
private exchange and that's linked to
this more general shift towards greater
cost
responsibility on uh on workers even
within employer-sponsored insurance i'm
wondering about another side of that
which is hasn't received as much
discussion and that is the provider
networks within these plans um so if
we're just thinking for a moment about
the exchanges but also perhaps about the
direction that employers are going um
and also maybe you could expand a little
bit and diane you could talk to this one
perhaps about medicaid provider
participation and how it might be
affected so are people who are in these
plans going to have a hard time finding
doctors and hospitals that will accept
payments from from their insurers you
know one of the things that we're seeing
is that may not necessarily be the case
um these are private insurance plans
they previously had negotiated networks
they tend to be relying on their
negotiated networks one of the things
that we see attend towards are tighter
networks
but they're based on quality so some of
your quality concerns and they're based
on quality because they think that that
is a way that they can control costs or
even some of the private exchanges that
are out there that aren't necessarily
defined contribution approach but they
are going into a marketplace and they're
saying all right what is the narrow
network where i can control costs but
where there are quality providers so
i think there will be providers
available it's the same insurers it's
the same reimbursement patterns um the
incentives are staying the same but um
you know the the reasons that you're
seeing smaller networks may not be
because um
you have the payment differentials like
you do in medicaid what about medicaid
dan well in medicaid the congress did
enact uh raises in primary care
physician fees for 2013 and 2014 to try
and improve the primary care base for
individuals there's been historic
problems in getting access to care
through medicaid connecticut has not
been
on the bad end of that spectrum either
so that there's been much more use here
of community health centers as well as
the state is now managing in a
fee-for-service way
instead of using managed care plans for
most of the medicaid beneficiaries so i
think the access here has been fairly
good that's great now i just want to say
that a number of the questions can turn
our next panel subject costs so if you
ask a question about costs your answers
are are probably coming soon and i'm
just going to let zach say a few words
before we break for lunch
and wait first sorry let me just say
what a wonderful set of remarks and
presentation great presentations let's
thank our panelists
great so so this is ready to launch
we're about to ready to lunch i've been
waiting to say that for the
entire day i was expecting a way better
read i thought that was pretty fun
no
okay people are people are hungry zach
yeah so what we're gonna do is go out
and get our sandwiches bring them back
and then we're actually gonna hear from
senator murphy and then we're gonna
transition over to kevin coonahan who's
running access ct
the exchange we keep talking about the
other announcement is at the end we're
conscious that there are a ton of
questions um i'm gonna stay around the
senator staff's gonna stay around all
some of the academics will stay around
and we'll just hang out in the back and
any question that you don't feel like
got answered there pick on us ask us
your questions all right so grab your
lunch come on back and we'll transition
and hear from senator
actually believe it or not was filmed on
the way to the vote
to which vote was it i guess to to keep
the government moving vote yeah they're
nodding that ted cruz wanted to veto
because of the affordable care act so
here's senator murphy
hey it's chris murphy i am so sorry that
i wasn't able to be at the conference
today i want to thank jacob hacker
everyone at yale
all of the guests who have traveled from
outside of connecticut to join you there
today i want to especially thank joe
dunn on my staff who's there as well who
put a lot of work into organizing this
i've heard so far that it's been a
fantastic morning with a lot of great
information and of course it is stick
with irony that i cannot be there with
you today because i am here in
washington dc defending the very bill
that you're talking about implementing
uh as soon as i finish taping this video
i'm gonna walk into the united states
capitol and take a two-hour shift
presiding over the united states senate
during those two hours we will vote on a
continuing resolution and an amendment
to it that will strip out a provision
that the house added last week defunding
and stopping the implementation of the
health care law
we don't know what the next step is but
i think that the senate democrats and
the president have made it pretty clear
that there is absolutely no way that we
are going to allow for the repeal or the
defunding of the health care law and we
are not going to allow for the budget of
the federal government to be held
hostage these kind of politics you know
this isn't about politics for families
in connecticut and across the country
this is unfortunately about life or
death it's about potential bankruptcies
and you know in the course of the
15 years i've been working on
the goal of universal health care you
run across so many compelling stories
but i keep on coming back to the one
of betty burger and her family
the burgers live in meridian connecticut
and betty and her husband were model
citizens did everything right her
husband was
employed and changed jobs and in the one
week period
it was a two-week period but in the very
short period of time between
one job and the second job their son was
diagnosed with cancer
and because of that diagnosis the
insurer for his second employer refused
to cover their son
the burgers lost everything
they lost their house they lost their
car
they went through all the savings that
they
had
they
became bankrupt simply because their son
happened to get sick during the two-week
period of time in which the father was
out of work
the health care law ends that reality
and it is reality half of bankruptcies
in this country are caused by medical
debt in addition it dramatically lowers
costs for seniors who won't have to deal
with preventative
costs or the donut hole for all of the
kids out there who haven't been able to
afford health care
for the families that haven't been able
to get it because of a pre-existing
condition
we need to implement this law and we
need your help and so i know that you're
there today to ask questions about
details on the law and how it will
affect families in connecticut how you
can help get the word out
the enrollment period starts soon and
the success of the law really depends on
our ability to enroll the requisite
number of people that the exchange and
the insurers are expecting especially
young men and women the healthier
population in connecticut who will make
the insurance mix work in the end
now
just because we're going to
go to into the senate chamber today and
stand up for the existing health care
law doesn't mean that we aren't going to
have to come back here and amend it or
change it we're going to be working with
all the people in this room to watch how
this goes
and where we may have to come back and
make adjustments but that's what we
should be involved in the business of
perfecting the health care law not
repealing it because the burger story
unfortunately isn't the exception it's
too often the rule
and your help in learning more about the
aca today and then going out there and
making it a reality for families
throughout connecticut well it's just
going to make a big difference i'm sorry
i can't be there with you today
i would have done anything to do it but
if you turn on c-span uh in about an
hour at 12 30 or i don't know when
you're going to be playing this but
about 12 30 today we're going to take
four votes on the floor i'll be
presiding in the
senate chair and hopefully get to gavel
down a positive vote in favor
of health care for all connecticut
citizens have a great rest of the
conference
yeah so we don't have a video uplink we
don't have a video uplink from you guys
so that we can give a big round of
applause plus he is on the senate floor
right now we are going to spare you the
c-span coverage and instead
have a much more interesting uh
discussion i want to keep this really
short
because we have uh we've been running a
little behind we're i think just
completely fine but i want to
give uh kevin coonahan as much time as
possible to answer your questions which
he wants to do directly
up here
once he's made some introductory remarks
now for those who don't know
kevin was recently selected as the head
of connecticut's health insurance
exchange about which we've heard a lot
i'm told there were 75 candidates for
the position which means that he
actually won
out in a
in a selection process that had worse
odds than a mission at yale
and
he's
very well prepared for that job he's not
only worked
in
in creating a private insurance exchange
in california but also
he was
involved with the massachusetts
connector before that
and when he was brought here
the there was a you know a broad sigh of
relief
among
those involved in the health care effort
because uh we knew that this uh exchange
would be in the hands of someone who was
experienced in this in this area
and uh had specific experience um the
only real possibility of specific
experience that is in massachusetts and
the one of the the the pioneering
private insurance exchanges um that have
been created
i have to mention that he's a an adjunct
professor of health policy at
northeastern university since i i think
academics deserves special respect but i
want to mention something that i think
will probably give you more respect for
him than that and also uh is encouraging
me to keep my remarks uh very short and
and very friendly and that is that he's
a six sigma black belt which may well
come in hand i don't even know what that
means but it sounds extremely impressive
which may well come in handy uh in
handling the process of negotiating with
private health insurances in in
connecticut okay with the without
further ado i i welcome and we should
all welcome kevin coonahan
good afternoon everybody thank you much
so much for having me um and i apologize
too for the informality bringing my diet
coke up on the stage this in the past
six months this has become a new food
group so um it's been a lot of
sustaining on this um i want to talk to
you a little bit about where we are and
um
what are some of the issues that can
everybody hear okay
where some of the issues are going to be
sort of in the short intermediate and
longer term
um
so
let me just first tell you the following
which is that i'm very delighted to
announce to you that we are going to
have a fully functional stable and
operational exchange this tuesday uh
october 1st
thank you
thank you
we received our authority to connect
from uh hhs uh on monday
we finished the last of some fairly
complicated end-to-end testings with the
the federal data hub uh
we um spoke to cms yesterday and cesayo
and they told us that we've been given
the full granting to go ahead which is
called conditional approval because
the actually no state's going to get
full approval based on the sort of
complicated blueprint design that has to
be done so we're all set and we're ready
to go um
i i would tell you that i'm i just would
tell you up front i'm extremely proud of
the staff at access health connecticut
because
this team is not only experienced and
dedicated but
they are almost and i'm not saying this
is any um
knock on any uh work group they i hired
everybody from the private sector only
because they didn't have enough time
and um these guys are all used to
working with unrealistic deadlines not
enough money and sometimes irrational
bosses so they had that going in and
it's and i think it's worked out
reasonably well for us
so so this is where we're going so our
individual exchange is going to be up
and running on tuesday
our shop exchange which is the small
business health options program
that will also be up and running tuesday
october 1st we're going to be one of
five states
in the country that will actually be
offering
true employee choice
so example the federal model which is
being deferred as as you know by that
month um that's actually just going to
be a sole source model it's not going to
be the the the model where the employer
picks a reference plan and the employees
can either buy that or take money and
and buy something else ours will be that
um
we're opening up storefronts in new
haven and new britain uh around
mid-october they would have been earlier
but we just had a little bit of a
wrinkle with uh with a um
a certain vendor um so we're on church
street in new haven and we're the only
state in the country that's um that's
going to have storefronts we actually
stole that idea from uh the apple from
apple apple stores that's where we
ripped it off from um and we're actually
actually having our own version of a
genius bar in the back for people who've
got really complicated questions around
um dual eligibility and and and such of
that
um
we were written up in time magazine this
week as having the most consistent
advertising uh campaign uh that's all
relevant to a new brand like ourselves
because we want people to understand and
we want this to be a very safe place for
people to go so our call center has been
staffed to assume that the average phone
call is going to be 45 minutes
right now we take about 200 calls a day
on that on that number
for any of the people that are
interested it's 855
805
4325
and that's again 855
805
4325 so that's our call center number
and they are staffed as i said for an
average call of 45 minutes because
we want this environment to be something
that is safe for people to ask questions
people that are uninsured
newly insured
um find buying insurance to be very very
intimidating very very expensive
confusing and frankly they all think
they're getting shafted somewhere
they don't know by where or by whom but
all they know is something like this
should not be this expensive
and in our state in 2009 was the first
time that the average family premium
exceeded the uh the cost of the average
family mortgage
except the average family mortgage
doesn't go up eight to ten percent a
year
so you can just appreciate the that this
is a very very complicated uh decision
at the connector we found on average
that it took 18 touch points between
either the website the call center a
broker and a sister before somebody made
a decision to enroll so
we've been in touch with the people in
medicare part d
and they've persuaded us that we really
think our enrollment is largely going to
peak in two periods
the first is going to be the three week
period between post thanksgiving and
december 15th which is the deadline for
january first coverage
and the first two weeks in march which
is the absolute deadline overall
as i said we're going to be up on
tuesday we're going to be ready to take
applications we've connected
successfully with the hub
we've gone through all any of the sdlc
or software development lifestyle life
cycle people out there
we've worked through the entire testing
process we froze our code about two
weeks ago we're in production
and
we're tracking okay we're really
tracking well our defects both critical
and major have all been uh completed
successfully
and we were told by cms by this actually
very nice but very challenging person
that she was impressed and to get her to
be impressed uh is not easy so
we're
we're we're feeling we're feeling
reasonably good okay so what does it
mean now it means now that we're getting
to a part which is extremely complicated
and this is about outreach and
enrollment
our target is to have enrollment of a
hundred thousand people we would very
much like to exceed that if possible but
that's our target we've communicated
that to the white house matter of fact
uh several of us were invited to a call
with with the president about two weeks
ago to talk about our outreach efforts
and one of the things that um
that i mentioned was that we were doing
a number of things to try to get young
people enrolled and raise awareness and
one of which was um sponsoring concerts
at the comcast in hartford and he said
well that's an interesting idea so how
did that go and i said well it went
reasonably well i said we began with uh
with little wayne um whose birthday it
is today by the way for all of you
rapper fans
um and i said you know i'm not exactly
in the target demo for lil wayne but uh
you guys said i went and i said the
opening act was a guy named t.i
and i went backstage and got to meet t.i
and i've been working on this so long i
called him i.t
and
he
he said it's ti man and i said okay
sorry
so so
that type of communication that type of
outreach is very very important it's
very very critical so for example
getting young people which we're
defining basically is 18 to 34 right now
tends to be a little bit more nuanced
and challenging because there is a
broader sense particularly among young
men that they don't need to have health
insurance or that it's a bad buy
the kaiser family foundation poll that
came out in august seemed to debunk some
of that and it seemed to suggest that
it's not a matter of not feeling like
they need it they just feel like they
can't afford it and when you look at the
prices
with the subsidies
it's going to be very affordable we have
172 000 individual insurance policies in
our state and this is a state of 3.5
million people we have 9.6 percent
uninsured which is about 344 000
and of those 172 thousand 72 percent are
going to be eligible for subsidies
so the second wave of our advertising
campaign which launches in about two
weeks is called real people real
security and it's all based on profiles
of nine either individuals or families
who are going to be specifically
benefiting from the aca
i by the way you know do whatever you
want i never call it obamacare and the
reason why is because it just gets it
becomes ideological and political as
soon as it's used
i mean you know there's like 42 percent
are against it 37 percent are opposed to
it there's like seven percent in the 42
they're opposed to it because it doesn't
go far enough and i would argue to you
that the vast majority on either side
don't know what they're talking about
they just like it or hate it because
they either like or hate the president
but they really don't understand the law
what we need to do in our campaign is to
actually communicate the benefits
of health reform so for example
nowhere not as you know pre-existing
conditions are no longer going to be
excluded people will no longer be rated
differentially based on medical
underwriting or health status women
which in our state and many of you may
know this
can can be charged up to a hundred
percent more in premium for the same
plan at the same age all that goes away
preventive care visits but all those
kinds of things you know recently i was
at a town hall meeting and we do a town
hall meeting just about every night in
darien and darien as i think you may
know is not exactly a hotbed of the
uninsured
and so
and going down there i you know i was
you know you get whacked on occasion at
different communities for for different
things and i assume that this is going
to be another one of those evenings
we began talking about some of these
provisions and reforms
six people got up and talked about
challenges that they were having either
with their husband no longer being able
to make a job change because of a
pre-existing condition they couldn't get
insurance the stories just went on and
on and the reason that's so important we
believe in our state
is because that will help people focus
above some of the inevitable operational
noise now many of you know that i've
been saying for over a year now that
we're going to have glitches in this
we're already having glitches and look
you know our site is very stable right
now
that's not going to be the case all the
time
our call center is going to give out
misinformation
without meaning to the federal data hub
is going to be down we know it's down
from 1 to 5 a.m eastern every day
because of maintenance with ssa
but
these things are going to happen if you
look at social security so excuse me if
you look at medicare in 1965 that took
roughly 10 years to stabilize from the
people i've talked and what i've read
part d medicare part d took about three
years to stabilize this is going to take
three years to stabilize and enrollment
which begins on tuesday is also a
three-year project the opponents of
reform
are going to say on wednesday october
3rd or excuse me october 2nd that the
whole thing's a failure because 7
million people haven't enrolled
and and that's just sort of the
inevitable buzz that comes when you do
something big and bold like this
this is not perfect legislation but tell
me one bill that is
does this need tweaking like the senator
said absolutely it does
and it needs a group of adults from both
parties in dc to come together and think
and be rational and and make those
changes that will happen right now it
seems like adults are a little bit of a
rare commodity in dc but that will
change and this will all improve and in
10 to 20 years our kids and grandkids
are going to look at us at a time when
we had 50 million people uninsured 17 of
the country and they're going to say
what were you thinking
so this is a time we're taking the first
step of a three-year journey to correct
that and we will correct it and we're
very excited about it
so that's sort of the short-term stuff
so let me talk to you about um
the next stage so that's sort of 1.0 2.0
is going to move into helping people buy
insurance
and i think if you if you've read the
papers at all you know that we're we're
moving into a world of the 401k of
health insurance
so if you looked at what time warner
ibm
uh darden uh sears uh
walgreens others are doing is beginning
to give either retirees early retirees
or even active employees defined
contribution vouchers to go on to a
private exchange and say buy your own
insurance
employers have been looking for
something like this for decades because
it gives them the ability to budget
future expense
at present they don't know what to
expect and that's one of the reasons
they slash the benefits every year
because they're trying to keep it within
a budget
but that's evolving now we can debate
whether that's good or bad if you look
talk to the fortune 50 companies that
recently had a seminar on this issue of
401k plans there's real concern among
the fortune 50 that in fact this next
batch of retirees have actually not
saved enough money in their 401k plans
for successful retirements so that's a
whole other different issue but people
right now do not know how to buy health
insurance they don't understand it they
don't understand the terms the stuff
that you and i all take for granted they
don't co-pay deductible co-insurance
out-of-pocket max networks we all think
that's sort of interesting stuff well
guys 99.9 percent of the country
actually finds it pretty dull
they just want something they can
understand that provide some protection
and that they can afford
so helping people buy insurance giving
them decision support tools that are
actually actionable helping them
understand what to look for in selecting
providers
is going to be the next stage and a key
tangible output of this is the all-payer
claim database which is coming out in in
october of 2014. we our state's been a
little bit behind the curve but we're
catching up really fast
so uh in a year
will be the first will be our first
batch of reports where individuals will
be able to go on to a website type in a
procedure like an mri put in a zip code
and they'll be they'll be able to see a
scan of charges
for that procedure by that zip code by
the provider by the county and really
start making this retail experience
driven down to the provider level we
need to provide are starting to real
compete really compete right now and
have any of you ever asked a provider
what a procedure costs before you've had
it
anybody okay you're not you're not
atypical almost nobody does did they
know
yeah okay you're that's the exception
most times it's like it's like you might
as well be asking something in a foreign
language they don't know what
something's cost because it's all been
dictated to them by an icd-9 code or
cpt-4
that's all changing so we're taking the
veil off the costs and that's going to
be a very very important change for us
so that's going to be another element
how to buy insurance what to look for in
a health plan all these things are
things that act that access health ct
are going to need to move into and
that's really 2.0
3.0 and this is going to be three years
out it's going to be all about data
the the interview we've set up a
division of access health uh connecticut
called access health analytics
and that's housing the all pair claim
database but it's also going to be
housing uh a very big database to help
individuals
understand how to buy insurance and to
start looking at better quality metrics
for providers because the five-star
ranking that people use to buy almost
any consumer good right now
is going to be going into health plans
as well as to providers and there's
going to be enormous pushback and squawk
and and claims that this isn't properly
risk adjusted and my patients are the
sickest and all these kinds of stuff but
when people are spending more and more
of their own cash
they want real information on how to
make decisions
so more and more i believe that
nationally
the future of exchanges is around data
and information and decision support
tools
so will the consumer experience to be
able to shop and buy insurance be
important absolutely that's fundamental
it's the foundation will that experience
get better more intuitive clearer and
add more value to the customer
absolutely will we get more health plans
to actually compete in the marketplace
you bet we know harvard pilgrim from
massachusetts is coming in next year
i've been in contact with two other uh
health plans from out of state they're
interested in potentially coming into
our state and this is what we want we
want competition because competition
works to the benefit of citizens and
small businesses we want them to come in
we want them to fight it out in the
marketplace so that's going to be an
assumption
but i think for us to maintain a
leadership role which nationally which
we've done so far apparently on the
exchange side is we have to get ahead of
the curve with respect to decision
support tools and decision-making data
to help people really understand costs
and help drive more competition in the
delivery system
so with that let me take some questions
if there are any
yes sir
oh the call center yeah it is 855
eight oh five
two five
four three
you bet
yes
um
well it was it was less about the
affordability issue as much more about
pre-existing conditions and medical
underwriting and a frustration that you
know if somebody had a certain type of
health condition that you know and their
and their neighbor bought the same plan
at the same age that their price was you
know 27 more because of this health
condition so it was kind of this sense
of um
feeling that um you know the rules
weren't really very fair and equal for
everybody
sorry
for the folks
okay i apologize the the question had to
do with what were the key issues that
came up at the town hall meeting in in
darien and the issues again
were less about
plan design or affordability or price it
was more about such things as being
denied for pre-existing conditions
and being charged differently for
um having a health condition
and frankly for being a female there
were a couple of women who um hadn't
heard that they were being charged more
they tweeted somebody during the talk it
came out that they were paying like 80
more than somebody else and that got
their attention
yes sir or ma'am
working with or not working
well they're they're working um we're
working very closely with uh the i'm
sorry the the question was how are
hospitals in our state in connecticut
working or not working with the exchange
to help implement the aca and the answer
is that they're working collaboratively
with us
um the connecticut hospital association
for example
is in very routine contact with us we've
trained uh staff in the ers in the
admissions offices of those hospitals
that's ongoing by the way we've trained
staff and of all the community health
centers
as well
because that's going to be also a very
fertile source
i was down at at a board of directors
meeting at the one in middletown on last
saturday uh to talk about uh those
efforts
um
and so i would tell you i think that
they're they're being very helpful
that you know that being said i'll just
share something else with you that one
of the major systems uh saw me about six
months ago to uh to talk about what they
could do to help
and they told me how great they were and
all the good stuff that they were doing
and all these quality programs and all
that good stuff and they said you know
what can we do to really be assistance
of assistance to you
and i said
uh and i knew what they wanted to hear
they wanted to hear that there could be
links on their website and brochures in
the offices and i said cut your costs
you want to help
you got to bring the cost down
and i said well you know you're right
and we hear you and we're in the process
of this major efficiency move and this
big effort and we're targeting
uh you know this
this x dollars amount of of reduction
and you know kevin this is like you know
changing a battleship it's very very
complex and i said you know that's
fabulous you know good for you and good
for your your your management team but i
said just out of curiosity
what does that x dollars represent as a
percentage of your revenue
and so after heming and hong it turned
out it was like two percent
and i said well you know that's
wonderful i said i said but i just have
a question
do you think that industries that are
really out to transform
and really have sort of a bold vision
for being highly efficient and being and
being as cost effective as possible
would set a goal of two percent
do you think it might be a little bit
higher than that
and they said well you're right and they
went back to the battleship analogy and
all that stuff but my point is we've got
the fourth highest medical costs in the
country
we know that this is a drag on jobs
we know that this is unsustainable
we're we're we're running the risk of
actually being a three hospital system
and this is this issue is not going away
irrespective of health care reform
so we're all gonna have to work together
but this is a big big issue that we're
all going to have to address
ted
kevin first of all i think we i speak on
behalf of everyone in this room by
saying i'm so glad we have somebody of
your
running this exchange
because i think you you are the right
person for this job two questions
one is um
the you know responding to the story
today in the current you know about
premiums i'm just worried that that's
going to be fodder for people who say
see this is not working okay so can you
can you respond to that question the
second question
is regarding uh the narrow networks that
we've heard so much about and the people
that have now applied to go become a
part of the connecticut exchange can you
talk briefly about the network
coverage of those offerings on the
exchange
thank you those are two helpful
questions um the first is the article in
the current which um
quoted some data that came out of hhs
earlier in the week um that listed um
are an average price for connecticut for
the second lowest cost
silver plant and just for some little
cocktail chit chat by the way my wife is
responsible for metal to metal tears
just you know when i was back at the
connector
we had this idea of creating tears and
being a good marketing mba i came up
with these ideas like the revolution
plan the liberty plan the constitution
plan
and i used to run him by her at night to
get her opinion and she used to say
that's a bad idea that's a worse idea
and she she finally said to me one night
look all your ideas are bad
why don't you name him after the
olympics gold silver bronze everybody
gets that and just sort of be done with
it so that's her contribution national
health reform
um
but but but it quotes this this this
story uh that ted refers to um where uh
in the hhs data it shows 436 dollars as
a base rate for the average second
lowest silver plan in connecticut and
i've got to be i got to be frank with
you i told the radio uh interviewer
today this as well which is
they asked us to audit that data and
gave us no time to do it we're not clear
if that's right or not it might be right
but it's it runs a little bit contrary
to our understanding and the
understanding of our actuaries we want
to send that data to our actuaries
because as you may may or may not know
we hired an independent actuarial firm
to look at all the health plan
submissions that act actually acted as a
second set of eyes to the insurance
department and they've they know all
this stuff cold but they gave us no time
to do it because i think they really
want to rush that story out the second
is they were comparing plans in our
state and this is touching on ted's
second question
we have we're gonna have pretty broad
networks for our standardized plan
designs
and
many of the other states including my
old state of california it's just the
opposite matter of fact in talking to my
counterpart there many of the plants in
california have actually taken their
original network and cut it in half
well guess what if you've got a neural
network you do get a lower price so
you've got to adjust for all those
things
we also have 63 benefit mandates we have
probably more benefit mandates than any
other state in the country
um so you know there's all these kinds
of things that factor in into cost
and um
it's just you know that makes great
headlines and i agree that that is going
to be something that um is going to
follow us for a while but one of the
challenging parts from our perspective
is that now we're actually being saddled
with that as another challenge so in
fact actually setting up an exchange
isn't good enough we now actually have
to reduce costs in connecticut which is
a way above our pay grade by the way
um
but but
we are working um we we did something
that was fairly unique we actually took
this from massachusetts we have
standardized plans
for all the carriers under the metal
tiers so so a consumer can look under a
silver plan and not have to worry about
whether kinetic hair's got a different
uh benefit level than anthem which is
different than healthy ct they're all
the same
and it makes it so much simpler to be
able to compare price network brands
services
that's really what the consumers care
about they actually don't want 87
choices they really don't research shows
this they like seven choices or nine
choices what they ideally wanted
actually is low medium and high gold
silver bronze they really wanted this
sort of nine element matrix
well you know we've got a piece of that
and a good piece the second o the second
though is that we do we did give each
carrier the option of two customized
plants per metal tier now they didn't
all use them
but but most of them did and those plans
can include narrower networks to bring
the price down now we don't know those
networks until monday
but we know more more importantly that
the qualified health plan criteria that
the board established for the
standardized plans has to include broad
networks
and the ceos of the of the plans have
told us that they've gotten us there so
right now i have to take them at their
word the one that i think is still
struggling a little bit is healthy ct i
think they're still building their
network
yes ma'am
so so the question had to do with mental
health coverage and is that a core
benefit and how does it compare with
most plans in the state right now it is
as i think most of you know an essential
health benefit it is one of the 10
categories of ehb how it compares to the
standard plan in connecticut i actually
have to get back to you on
but um
my sense is and please correct me if i
got this wrong that in our state in
general our policies are are reasonably
rich in that regard
if and if that's not true please please
tell me i don't know whether parity is
always administered consistently or not
but
i'd have to get back to you in terms of
analysis
yes kevin i have a question which came
up in some of the carts that we passed
around earlier which is obviously
at the time that
the connecticut was moving forward a
couple years ago there was the idea of
sustenance on the table
and perhaps you could explain to people
what that was what happened to it and
your own thoughts about whether or not
some kind of public insurance plan
obviously i have somewhat of a parochial
interest here but but i'm curious just
your own perception
well
you know i have to admit i i read the
sustenant report and so the question had
to do with um uh commenting a little bit
about sustenant which was um and i'm not
going to say this right so uh was it
basically a public option plan in the
state was that basically it okay um so i
read the report which i thought was
quite good and very helpful um i knew
from my massachusetts days um several of
the people that were on the committee
like john gruber from mit who's on the
connector board
um
so i don't know what happened to it i
mean that this is like pre my entry into
the state so i'm not really sure the
dynamics of what happened to it um
i would tell you sort of an aside that
hhs has just released um a notice of
proposed rulemaking in nprm for basic
health plan regulations so that came out
a week ago it's 110 pages i'm still
working through it um but um i know
there's interest uh by segments in our
state of of looking at bhp
washington state was the one that's
really the most um aggressive in this
regard and that is actually named after
the washington state plan it's actually
called the basic health plan
i don't i don't that whole responsive
i'm sorry that wasn't too responsive to
your question
okay
yes sir
okay um would you
talk a little bit about the transition
of enrolling in medicaid from the
traditional dss system to the portal and
and their access help sure the question
there had to do with the medicaid
enrollment transition between dss
enrollment and into the exchange and i
have to acknowledge upfront that i'm i'm
not an expert in medicaid in connecticut
nor in medicaid enrollment
but what i can tell you is that medicaid
enrollment in the exchange is going to
be no different than enrollment in any
other type of category and let me tell
you how that will work pretty briefly
so an individual or family will come
into our portal which is access
accesshealthct.com
and they will click a button that says
apply for insurance
and they will be asked for certain uh
financial
demographic and geographic information
that information is then sent along 16
pipes
to different state and federal agencies
for validation in essence is what you
say true
you may be pleased to know that
connecticut served in a leadership role
to exclude a key question from the new
application that would have been in
which was what is your zodiac sign
that was originally in the federal
government's new single stream
application
our focus group testing showed that
people found that a little weird
and
pretty much asked why we were asking
we also excluded another question by the
way this is a footnote to the man's
question which is they also asked what
is your monthly car payment
and but they didn't have a box that said
none
so we surveyed 450 people on the
application and they said well we don't
have a car payment and we didn't know
what to tell them because there was no
box that said no
anyway those two are gone from the new
application but they put in this
information and they get slotted into
three categories one is medicaid
eligibility two is is is eligibility for
tax subsidies and the third is
unsubsidized commercial insurance
if they're in the medicaid
if they're eligible for medicaid
there is actually um and this is not
optimal right now but there is a pdf
that the enrollee doesn't know this but
behind the scenes the pdf is actually
sent to dss
and that pdf unfortunately has to be
manually entered into their system
that the old ems system um
for them to then to get coverage
now my understanding from speaking of
the folks at dss and i know there are
others in the audience that are much
more expert than this than i is that
probably by the end of 15 2015 that
should all be automated and we should
have true uh no wrong door or integrated
eligibility which means just like for
anybody else the tax subsidies the
unsubsidized comp people that that
information will go directly into the
into the system but right now it's a
manual
kevin process is the easiest way for
people who have additional questions
about the exchange to get in touch with
your office so there's a couple of
things i think one would be the website
we've gotten pretty good reviews on the
website with respect to uh
the an faq section
um there is a um
a subsidy calculator so that's getting a
lot of usage so people come into the
website they go to the to the calculator
to try to get an estimation as to
whether or not they would be eligible
for subsidies or not they can call our
office which is 860-757-5300
and
any of you can call me
860-757-5553
let me just say one thing please
um i talked about this being a
three-year
journey
this is not up to the exchange to have
to implement it's not up to segments to
implement i generally believe that this
is shared responsibility for the
citizens of connecticut
we have to accept i believe we have that
having health insurance needs to be a
core value of our state and that we as a
state
and as a society in the state are better
off with people being insured than not
being insured and i think when we accept
that value
all the other stuff whether it's you
know washington you know shuts down you
know defunding all that nonsense goes
away this is a core value
and we appreciate all your help
thank you thank you so much uh kevin for
being here today um i know that you
can't accept it but we have a case of
diet coke waiting for you outside
outside the door but we didn't get to
see any karate moves um but we're going
to move directly into our next panel um
so we have zach
and and john schwartz coming up for the
table
so
zak has already been introduced and
we've got to see him uh several times
today but i want to introduce our other
panelist um john schwartz who is the
head of the montefori medical group it's
a he's a remarkable history uh in
medicine uh and business he is an md mba
which can all make us people who only
have one two or three letters after our
names uh phil i feel like we didn't work
hard enough um back in grad school um he
uh right now oversees 11 primary care
practices with over 450 000 visits
annually um he's not doing that himself
but he is a practicing uh physician so
he brings a unique perspective to the
discussion uh we're going to bring begin
with zach and then we'll move to john
fantastic all right
so
what i want to focus on today is the
cost of healthcare
and we often talk about this issue of
cost and access separately that there
are two separate issues in fact i think
they're absolutely related
okay if we can't get costs under control
much better if we can't get costs under
control
we can't guarantee access okay the
reason giving universal health care in
this country is so difficult
is because costs are so extraordinarily
expensive and the sort of the telltale
sign about how costs are are so
important so mike mullen was chairman of
the joint chiefs under president bush
and president obama and his last task in
office was to do a threat assessment
looking forward for the next 50 years
and he looked out at cyber security and
rogue states
loose nuclear weapons
and what he came back to was debt
and what he acknowledged was that the
leading driver of our debt was health
care spending
i'm going to make a core argument today
which is that
what we need to think about is how we
pay for health care
okay that right now we have a system
that pays for quantity
how much is given
we need to move towards a system that
pays for quality
the sooner that happens the better we're
going to do
so this is sort of the the tried and
true graph for a health economist it's
the relationship between how much we
spend on health care and how wealthy our
country is
it turns out that wealthier countries
spend more that's not surprising
this explains 88
of the variation in spending across
different countries
okay so 88 of of the variation between
how much we spend in england spends in
france spends is explained by the fact
that we're richer
except for the united states
the u.s spends 700 billion dollars more
than our wealth would predict that we
should
now the challenge is that's despite no
evidence
that we do massively better in health
outcomes
that's in spite of the fact that we
leave 50 million americans uninsured
and all of the challenges you've heard
today
and the answer is we can't go on
spending more
and getting less
and what's so ironic about this and this
is going to be one of the themes that
comes across throughout my presentation
is it turns out spending less usually
gets you better care
there are a plethora of examples of
where the cheapest hospitals in the
country turn out to be the ones that are
offering the best outcomes
okay this is the the graph that i think
should give us
a bit of of anxiety
what it shows is the relationship
between state spending
which is on the x-axis there at the
bottom
and the quality of healthcare in those
states
the easy interpretation is spending more
gets you less
this is why spending more year after
year is so problematic for us in this
country
that spending more isn't getting us
better outcomes
it's good money after bad
and it's crowding out the the investment
that we need in programs like education
infrastructure science r d
and we're putting in funding uh
increased spending into a wasteful
system
okay this i i like to pick on harvard
and mass general because well we're at
yale so i can
what this is showing is the the quality
scores for three large academic medical
centers in the united states this is
ucla mass general and the mayo clinic
and the key takeaway here
is that the highest quality hospital
mayo clinic
also has the lowest costs
okay that this this scare that that if
we slow spending down we're going to get
worse outcomes really isn't true
that the best outcomes in the us are
from facilities that generally charge
the lowest prices
okay this is to give us a sense of
context you're asking me why in the
world i've put this up so this is the
gdp of the 10 richest countries and
we've got the usual suspects the united
states china
great britain all the way down to russia
in 10th place
i've made a crucial omission
the united states healthcare system
where if it were a country would be the
sixth richest country in the world
that's extraordinary so vladimir putin
talks about u.s exceptionalism
we spend more on health care than russia
not then russia spends on health care
than russia
and sort of it's exceptional to think
about how much
we spent
and the question is why
okay
we don't hospitalize you more
we have fewer doctors you're in the
hospital for a shorter period where does
it come from why do we spend more
and the simple answer is that when you
touch the health care system in the
united states your costs are
extraordinary
okay we do more per hospitalization
than any other nation in the world
and what i'm going to argue is that
that's a function in large part to how
we pay
for healthcare and and that's what we
need to change there's great work by by
david cutler who's an economist at
harvard basically showing one of the
things you can do is look at folks who
live on either side of the canadian
border who who generally look pretty
similar
and it turns out that if you're in
canada and you have a heart attack
you're 50 less likely to have a coronary
artery bypass graft or an angioplasty
the kicker is you live just as long
okay this variation in and of itself
explains 14 of the difference in
spending between the two countries
so so why are we so expensive
okay i have my own triangle it's a
little different from what we saw
earlier
i would argue that at every point in the
system
the incentive in the united states is to
do more
okay that that we pay providers fee for
service based on fee for service which
is one payment per activity the
incentive there is to provide more
activity
that we have malpractice laws
that encourage doctors at the margins to
order more not less in order to avoid
being sued
it's because over time we've actually
seen and it doesn't feel like it but
insurance become much more generous
we have medigap policies that take away
our co-pays and make absolutely no sense
and shield individuals from the real
cost of health care
and so that every incentive on the
system in the system
is to do more and so when the doctors
who want to do the best that they can
but when they're considering what to do
every piece of evidence every incentive
in the system is to offer
that next piece of health care
i was an adviser to a politician who
said it was
a great line that i shouldn't repeat out
loud but he said you want to know the
best way to get a message to a doctor
write it on a check
the way we pay hospitals the way we pay
physicians
is i think in large part
why we see costs being so high so this
this same politician he he was really a
fan of aviation safety
if any of you fly or ridden the cockpit
of a plane you'll see these checklists
that pilots go through it's actually
they're they're going through it now in
this photo
and they'll go through it the the the
flaps work the ailerons work it's my
electrical system turned on
and one of my co-authors peter pronovos
did a checklist in healthcare so one of
the biggest issues
at least in terms of patient safety are
central lines that's what the the fellow
there on the right is getting
we put in about five million a year
about five percent of these get infected
25 of these infections are fatal
we lose 28 000 people from these
infections each year at a cost of about
2.3 billion dollars
okay what peter did is he came up with a
five point checklist pretty simple stuff
if we wash our hands we clean the
patient's skin
if we dress ourselves in sterile
dressings if we dress the patient in
sterile dressings he argued it would
make a best big difference we did a
randomized controlled trial
it reduced infections to zero
to zero
and what we've got to be asking
ourselves is why isn't this done
everywhere
okay in aviation safety you'd never see
a pilot take off without going through
it why don't we see this in healthcare
and i would argue it's a question of
incentives
on that plane the pilot's going down
with the ship
in healthcare you actually get more
money as a hospital
for having an infection
because you're billing for the services
to treat the infection
that doesn't mean you know physicians
are trying to get their patients
infected but but there's no incentive
everything is pushing you away from
doing what we know is already right
this is where the affordable care act
comes up
what they're trying to do albeit slowly
is change the way we pay for health care
okay so i'm going to talk about four
four ways they've changed one is paying
for quality
so what they're going to do is offer
less money
to hospitals that have high readmission
rates
and high infection rates they're just
simply going to say we're not going to
pay you as much
full stop
step in the right direction
i'm going to not talk a little bit about
what you're saying he's going to talk a
lot about accountable care organizations
and essentially the idea here is to
create a network of providers
we're going to predict what their costs
are and if you can have as an
organization costs that are lower than
expected you keep the profits
which changes the incentives then it's
not an incentive to do more
it's an incentive to promote health
we're going to introduce bundled
payments because this idea is paying for
everything from the day you get care to
30 days after
so that all of a sudden having a
readmission cuts into your profits
it's aligning the incentives in the
system and one of the the key you know
this is actually what most of the pa the
affordable care act
about a hundred words were about
insurance 1900 words were about this
payment reform so most of the words are
really about this and the technical
wiring
what they're going to do is introduce
all these demonstration projects
because it turns out one percent of the
population this is extraordinary one
percent is responsible for 20 percent of
the country's spending
5 of the country
is responsible for 50
okay so we've got this very very small
concentration of patients who are
exceedingly expensive
and so one of the trials that they're
doing up at harvard boo
uh but it's still still a good trial now
one of the the trials that they're doing
is paying harvard to manage these
patients
okay so they're they're predicting what
the spending is going to be
they're paying them a capitated basis so
an amount per patient and then seeing if
they can manage these patients
effectively
over the next several years okay we now
have results and and the reality is so
harvard's going to foot the the bill for
the costs and they're allowed to keep
five percent of the profits and then
they split the rest of the profits with
the government
okay what happened when we changed the
way that we paid we saw that
hospitalizations went down by 20
for these patients and and by the way
these patients are exceedingly expensive
so
see the on average they're taking 13
medications
uh 3.4 hospitalizations per year at a
cost of about 25 000 annually for this
very very sick group
by changing the way we paid we were able
to reduce hospitalizations by 16 20
percent
emergency admissions by 16
total cost by 12
from changing the way we structure
payments
now diane talked a little bit about this
the challenge is can we get these
innovation projects into the law
there is such gridlock in washington
that we're not able to get these fixes
in
one of the most extraordinary things in
the u.s is that the way we pay hospitals
is set by congress
let's see whether that's a good idea so
so this is a drug called avastm that is
iffy map
you don't want to have to take a vast
it's a drug that treats very very
aggressive cancers lung cancers
colorectal cancer kidney and ovarian
cancer
so for lung cancer it's going to extend
your life about three months at a cost
of about a hundred thousand dollars so
if it was my mother i would absolutely
want to have it i think it should be
available but we gotta ask how good a
job it does
this is a hugely expensive drug for for
marginal benefits
there was a study by tom lynch at yale
and and jennifer tremel
and what they looked at was when you
have a patient with lung cancer
what happens when you give he or she
very very early palliative care
and why am i mentioning this so this was
actually what gave rise to the
discussion of death panels
it was the funding of palliative care so
it's worth seeing what happens when we
do this
and so what they tried is they gave half
the patients in this study all the
cancer medications they could ask for
the second half got that they got
perfect oncological care but in addition
they got palliative care so they had
somebody talk to them about end of life
issues
talk to them about feeling as healthy as
they could with this very very serious
disease and the question is what
happened
okay so this is the quality of life
scores these are called fact l's
okay well this isn't terribly surprising
you know the group who got palliative
care had higher quality of life i mean
we some level would expect that that's
not terribly surprising i think it's
important but not surprising
okay people got palliative care were
less depressed
okay so the first two are measures of
anxiety in the hospital the third is a
clinical measure of depression
and they were substantially less
depressed
in addition they consumed fewer cancer
drugs so they were much less expensive
to treat
this is the extraordinary slide
they lived three months longer
they were happier they were less
depressed they spent less and they live
longer
okay this is why we need to change the
way we pay for health care
this is also why we need to take the way
we pay for health care out of the hands
of congress
and what i'm going to argue is we
probably need to create a federal
reserve
that manages hospital payments in the
same way that the federal reserve
manages interest rates
okay that we as a government just
because of politics don't have the power
to set these rates on a daily basis okay
we can't get out of our own way
and what we need to do is think about
how we set these prices how we pay
physicians and take it out of the
day-to-day fluctuations of government
we spend more than everybody else
i argue that's a function of how we pay
them
the aca is changing the way we pay
but we need to go further
and it's slowly moving us from as a body
as a correctional body the group who's
setting rates
to having that become apolitical all
right so with that i'm going to
transfer over to jonathan and we'll
hopefully continue the discussion
thank you very much and i'm really happy
to be here today i omitted from my bio
that i was born in new haven i think at
yale new haven and uh grew up in
cheshire did all my undergraduate work
at uconn and my medical school at uconn
so it's nice to be back in connecticut
so what i'd like to take you through is
uh just an introduction to our health
system i think it will help to
contextualize
understanding our aco
monofior has actually been managing
insurance risk and managing care for
over 15 years now
essentially meaning that
in the places where we have or the
insurers with which we have full risk
arrangements they give us some
percentage of the premium
something in the low 90s
percentage of the premium that they
either receive from an employee employer
medicare or medicaid and then we manage
all the care pay all the bills
and that
gives us the operated opportunity to do
some things that simply don't work in
fee-for-service medicine so i'm going to
talk a little bit about what the care
management cmo
short for it
what they do and how we do it
and then talk for a few minutes about
some of the challenges that have been
presented to us by the pioneer aco
in the way that it's structured and how
we're meeting those and then talk about
our first year results
so
bronx is an interesting place to work
it's
one of the poorest congressional
districts in the country
very high burden of chronic disease
our rates of diabetes and asthma and
coronary disease are well above national
average and highest in new york city
a lot of use of expensive hospital care
and
overwhelmingly 80 percent of the people
in the borough are covered by either
medicare or medicaid
the montefiore system
includes four hospitals
we have around
1500 beds in those four hospitals
we have 26 primary care sites
22 of them are in the montefiore medical
group which is in my home
and
those are almost exclusively primary
care practices
we have a very large school health
program we're in 20 schools throughout
the bronx
and
as well as having a mental health
network
large mostly faculty practice specialty
practices uh dental and imaging
so
i think i'm going to need my glasses for
this one
so um
this is a look at our revenue related to
insurance risk the the cmo started in i
think 1997 with 5 000 members
in 2000 we took over a contract from
what was then health insurance plan of
new york hip now emblem
which brought us about 120 000 members
and really expanded our scope
but in 2013 we now have a 140 000 lives
in full risk contracts another 78 000 in
some type of shared risk agreement
and
we are a medicaid health home contractor
so we're being paid to manage
care for another ten thousand enrollees
so 1.3 billion dollars
next year
we think that number is going to rise to
270 000 lives and about 1.8 billion
dollars which is about 50 of our
operating revenue
so that's a huge huge impact on us and
really allows us to begin
i think one of the one of the quandaries
that a lot of health systems are in now
is how do you prepare for a future of
population health management based on
quality when you're still getting paid
fee for service
getting paid fee for service doesn't
allow you really to invest in many of
the things that you need to provide
quality population health and i'll talk
about that a little bit more in a minute
so this is putting us kind of over the
marker of 50 percent where it makes
sense as a health system to to try to
move towards population health
so this is the care management
organization our cmo and
i i want to just run through some of the
programs that they run to talk about
how we do what we do
at the very top is intensive case
management this is a group of highly
trained nurses and social workers who
work with the most needy the sickest of
our sick patients often have in addition
to multiple chronic illnesses
psychosocial issues
and other problems
chronic care management
any of you that are in the health field
know about the field of disease
management well as a primary care
physician
a lot of the contact i have with disease
management from other payers is somebody
in utah or maybe india calling me to say
well you know i see on this emergency
room claim your patient has congestive
heart failure do you have this them on
this drug that people with congestive
heart failure are supposed to be on and
it turns out in fact you know the
diagnosis was wrong the patient doesn't
have congestive heart failure but that
type of disease management program isn't
really helping me take care of my sick
patients
our disease management programs are the
real deal so for example we have rns who
are certified diabetes educators
embedded in most of our primary care
sites and they do extensive education of
patients they take patients who are not
doing well with their diabetes they help
to motivate them to take more control
over their illness and they've done a
really fantastic job of helping them
improve our diabetes care they also
while they're added in building
relationships with these patients help
coordinate their care for those patients
that require work with multiple
specialists so the nurse that works with
me
might be you know gives patients her
cell phone she might have 10 calls over
the course of two or three days for a
patient where we're starting the patient
on insulin and they need rapid
adjustments based on what their blood
glucose is that kind of capability just
doesn't exist in in our system before
and in most health systems we also have
disease management for respiratory
disease asthma
mostly telephonic but also we have an
asthma center where patients get
extensively educated about their illness
they see a pulmonologist and allergist
get a plan of care and go back to their
primary care provider as well as a
congestive heart failure program
with telemonitoring in the home so that
as you may know people with congestive
heart failure their heart is not pumping
adequately they begin to build up fluids
in their body eventually they get lots
of edema in their legs they can't
breathe
the the minute somebody starts to tip
over and gain that extra weight maybe
they didn't take their medicine maybe
they had a high salt meal we're now able
to detect that either counsel them over
the phone or bring the patient into the
physician's office right away otherwise
three days later that would have been a
ten thousand dollar hospital admission
as their heart failure progressed
uh
zach mentioned palliative care we have a
good palliative care program at
montefiore and i think the you know the
real issue here is
not just
the fact that we're we're able to give
people better plans it's that we have
folks with enough time and enough
expertise to really talk with people
about how to plan what is going to be
the end of their life we're not doing
this with patients who have cancer that
can be easily treated these are p
patients with incurable illness where
the reflex of the health system and for
families that don't have support is you
call 9-1-1 when things start looking bad
and they're back in the hospital so this
allows people to have much better
symptom management and to be able to
create goals of care and a plan for how
to achieve them
whether that's hospice at home or other
ways
to to have a better quality of life at
the end
we have a managed behavioral care
program and we're beginning to
experiment now with integrated
behavioral care in primary care so again
you know our mantra for
most of my career has been if you can't
bill for it we can't do it because we
can't afford to do it in the office
so now we have
psychiatrists
in our offices or even connected
telephonically and through our
electronic medical record who will
consult with a social worker work with a
primary care physician send suggestions
around medication management that's not
a billable service so they you can't
afford to do it in the regular world
here where we're dealing with
essentially a capitated population we
can choose to expend these resources
that allows us to identify and treat
many many more patients with depression
many patients with depression have
chronic illnesses that they're not able
to manage well until you treat their
depression john i'm sorry to interrupt
but we have to wrap up around two that's
about 12 minutes from now so i'm
wondering if maybe we could move a
little bit toward some of the more
state and national issues around the new
kinds of health plans and payments under
the affordable care act sure thank you
so
i mentioned a number of these others
here care transitions i'll just say it
has a lot to do with people coming home
from the hospital many readmissions
which is a big problem in the united
states happens because people go home
unprepared don't get their medicines etc
and and we try to hold their hand
through that process
so on to the monofier aco
in 2012 we had 23 000 beneficiaries
most of them living in the bronx in
westchester there's the stats around
their average age and the diagnosis as
you would expect diabetes pulmonary
disease heart disease
we have a number of partners in our aco
beyond our own network st barnabas is a
community hospital in the bronx the next
two are federally qualified health
centers we would like to be able to take
as much of a regional approach to health
care as we can with those partners
north shore lij is in staten island in
brooklyn and we've developed a working
relationship with them where we're able
to offer care management expertise their
additional members allow us to spread
risk over a larger
population
so
the interventions that we've used in the
aco are exactly the same that we've been
doing for the last 15 years in the cmo
of
trying to manage people through
transitions doing good disease
management
we have case managers in our ers to help
patients who really don't need to be
admitted but getting them back to where
they need to be whether it's reinstating
home care
homeless people that need to get into
shelters often were admitted because
there was no place to send them they
they work to try and help make those
transitions work well
um one of the things that's been unique
about our aco about 60 of the the
members in our aco belong to physicians
that are not salaried by montefiore
they're private voluntary physicians out
in the community
some of them are still on paper records
uh it's been a and many of them are
specialists and as you may know some of
the aco quality measures
go to primary care has somebody had
their
pneumonia vaccine have they had their
mammogram not something specialists are
used to doing so we've really had to go
out and build relationships with a lot
of private physicians in the community
in order to make this work we have
bi-weekly quality meetings where some of
the
larger groups come in and join us and
talk about how we can
improve what we're doing
within the medical group we've had a
very large effort to become
patient-centered medical homes what that
really means for us is that we are
bringing in
over three years about 20 million
dollars of new staff nursing staff
patient education educators social
workers so we can really take a team
approach to giving the patient the best
care they can as opposed to the hurried
15-minute office visit being the only
way that you interact with your with
your physician
so in 2012 we were the most successful
pioneer aco in the country uh we had
about a seven percent reduction in cost
compared
compared with our target that's uh about
23 million dollars
a substantial portion of that stays with
cms a substantial portion of it will pay
for all the people that we had to hire
in order to manage this care and then
some of it will also go back to the
participating physicians for the work
that they invested in in quality
improvement
we did that with a 10 reduction in
admissions a 36 percent
reduction in readmissions in our group
and in 2012
one of the things that zach didn't
mention is that in an aco you only get
to share the savings if you hit quality
measures if you don't hit the quality
measures there's no savings return back
to the aco so in 2012 with the
requirement was only that you could
report all of the quality measures we
were able to do that and we're working
very hard now at a number of plans to
improve and make sure that we hit the
targets for next year
thank you john right great
well i think i think that's a great
opening for
i've gotten a lot of questions from the
prior
panels about costs that i'm going to ask
but i think that's a good opening for
talking about
zach this
fundamental point that you brought up
which might be summed up to uh uh
with the um phrase the prices are too
damn high
and that is that the us obviously has
extraordinarily high price levels
compared with uh other countries you
know even with medicare rates being
relatively high they're much lower than
most private insurance plans are paying
we've seen consolidation on the provider
side um so what is the
what is the um what is the prescription
that you would offer and obviously you
said we should be moving away from
paying fee for service well what what's
a path by which we could get there uh
how quickly could we travel it and how
much could it take place through the
work of ipab and maybe you can explain
what ipab is to the group sure so it's a
great question so essentially to distill
it down the price for hip replacement in
the united states is three times with
the prices for hip replacement in
virtually every other country and it's
the same thing we're not we're not doing
anything mythically different why is it
well some of it is that we've seen a lot
of mergers so
we're guilty of it yale new haven's
buying up everything in the surrounding
areas
and and when you have entities merge and
markets become more consolidated prices
go up
the other is that we've got a very very
concentrated
supply side the the hospitals and we've
got a lot of small insurers so so that's
sort of a recipe for it how do we fix
that
i think two ways so i think one is very
very rigorous antitrust enforcement and
and slowing down some of these mergers i
think the second which we don't talk
enough about is getting patients to
travel further so the the sort of
corollary to consolidation
is opening markets up so that if i'm
insured in new york my employer or my
insurer is willing to pay for me to fly
to the mayo clinic so that that becomes
a competitor and so that montefiore and
offense and yale feel some pressure from
these extraordinary providers in other
regions of the country and we make it
very very easy for people to go further
i think the third which is probably the
biggest most ambitious and most
difficult step
is probably saying that the way we price
health care services doesn't matter or
it doesn't work and that well yeah it
does matter
it doesn't work and that we probably
need to go to some sort of
regulated price setting where
there's a single group who's setting
prices for everything and and we figure
out some ways that there's still an
incentive for quality
but we just don't let the market clear
prices because i think oh you know i'm
an economist
markets usually do a pretty good job but
when it comes to health care all the
evidence right now is that we're not
setting particularly efficient prices
well john i wanted to ask you a question
about the
replicability or um that's the academic
term the transfer the degree to which
other
parts of the country already have
the kind of aco infrastructure that
you're talking about it sounds like it's
really on the cutting edge and obviously
we're quite interested in this
discussion and what might happen in
connecticut
and
in that answer i'd be very interested in
your view since given what you're
describing there's a lot more
involvement not just of
nurses
and and alternative
provider providers who are not
physicians uh but also of primary care
physicians how does this fit in with a
more general problem within the system
that has been long identified that
there's an imbalance in the incentives
for going into primary care versus
specialty care so
well it's certainly been a problem for
us and i think um you know primary care
over the years that i've done it has
become more and more difficult more and
more of a hamster wheel of you know more
visits
higher expectations less support
so what i'm certainly seeing in the last
three years is really a reversal of that
so that now we are reinvesting back in
primary care there's no question that
with
additional people being insured in the
united states we'll have a shortage of
primary care providers
but it's also very true that many of the
things that we've done in the office
face-to-face with the doctor was because
that's the only way that it was paid for
and if you can sort of free yourself
from those shackles either by prepayment
or by paying for quality it allows us to
invest in those things that can promote
quality so many of those things might be
handled over the phone with a nurse or
might be
might happen in a nurse visit or working
with a health educator or happen in an
email with me rather than a face-to-face
visit which then would of course
increase our available supply and i
think there's you know to build on that
it's allowing the workforce to diversify
and you and i being a little more
comfortable having a nurse give us an iv
and i
if anybody's ever been tattooed by an
attending trying to put in an iv they
sort of know that that four-year-old or
six-year-old physicians aren't the best
at it you know being a little more
comfortable that our our providers might
look a little different and that you
know physicians are going to look like
conductors of an orchestra but they're
not going to look like sort of the the
trumpet players in 30 years so john i
just want to follow up on that question
just ask you
what
so how
how many places in the country and
kinetic and to what extent within
connecticut in particular do you see the
infrastructure that might make this
possible over what time span
wow
i don't know that i have the answer to
that certainly there are some very large
integrated systems around the country
that are that are capable of this and
are doing it uh i think the ability for
someone to build this kind of
infrastructure relatively quickly in a
number of places
would be extremely difficult but i i do
think that the
the the move in that directions and even
in my own system the changes that i've
seen
as we've begun to reward quality rather
than volume it shifts the priorities in
the health system and it causes people
to invest and build in different ways so
i think the kind of care management
capability that we've built up would be
difficult to implement quickly in the
country
well i don't end on it on that kind of
note so maybe i'll turn finally to zach
um i i agree i think that's you're
absolutely right um it is a challenge
but also it's really impressive what
you've been able to do um so zack
you mentioned this idea of regulated uh
price setting at the same time we've
heard kevin talking about uh taking the
veil off of the cost that people should
know both quality and cost measures for
individual services and i'm curious
i asked the last question about the
independent payment advisory board and i
do want you to just explain that to
people very briefly but i'm curious my
last question is really um to what um
to what extent do you think that some of
the changes that are taking place
will spread out because remember we've
said medicare is primarily where this is
happening that will spread out into
other parts of the system what are the
incentives for that are they the kind of
incentives that kevin was talking about
with the seven percent or so the
population that may end up in the
exchanges shopping more aggressively
what's going to create that pressure
short of your federal reserve
so it's a great question an easy one to
end on
no problem um so so then you have to be
optimistic right yeah
so the independent payment advisory
board was sort of the brainchild of
peter orsack and and essentially the
idea here was we create a body where if
medicare rates were growing faster than
the predetermined amount this body could
come in and change the way we paid they
could they could come in sort of as a
sweeper for sort of the the navy seals
of health care and and introducing quick
payment changes that they got healthcare
spending under the control um this was
uh not received particularly well and to
put it charitably they didn't like the
idea of of moving the way we fell for
healthcare out of the hands of
politicians
and so the ipab now can't do anything
that influences your benefits they can't
raise revenue and i believe they can't
do anything that constitutes rationing
so i think the the potential for ipad is
limited i also think like just from a
practical sense would you really want to
sign up to be a member of this thing
it's sort of you know i don't know that
i'd volunteer to be a member of ipab
how does this spread
i think it spreads when we get to a
tipping point where employees and
employers say
enough
where you know a lot of these employers
are saying look in order to to remain
viable
in these insurance companies in order to
remain viable we have to change the way
we do business
and i think the real pressure is going
to come from firms employers we're going
to say look this isn't acceptable that
producing a car in the united states
costs a thousand dollars more than
producing a car in japan simply because
our health care is expensive we need to
change it and i think that
the business community actually in this
case is i think going to be the driver
for for seeing these sorts of payment
innovations spread
well i i hope that makes you feel
optimistic
so uh i would just say um a couple quick
uh closing remarks and um and zach has a
few of his own first of course we're all
looking forward to zero dark 2014 um
with the navy with our navy seals of
healthcare um and i just want to say
what a pleasure it's been to have these
presentations i hope you've agreed uh
that they've been really uh really
informative but even more important to
have all of you here asking questions
i'm sorry that we weren't able to get uh
to all of them and it was a real
pleasure to have uh chris murphy here
and his staff chris murphy here
virtually and his staff here
in person and i just want to thank again
them for helping us put together this
event and thank again the amazing staff
at isps uh including of course pam green
so let's just have a round of applause
for all of those things
so
i wanna i don't
we launched slightly late we were ready
but we launched slightly late i want us
to finish on time so my last comment is
simply this
we have a website it's
isps.yale.edu it's pretty easy to find
if you'd like to stay involved in the
work we're doing not just on healthcare
but on a host of other issues please go
there and sign up for our newsletter and
take a look at some of the research
we're doing
and and i would echo that
thank you guys for for coming this is
this is our first event um we're
going down new territory and it's it's a
blast so so thank you for coming out i'd
also like to thank pam as well for for
the extraordinary
efforts that she put in um
what we've tried not to say is that
healthcare reform the affordable care
act is good or bad
what we've tried to say is what works
and what doesn't and let you decide and
that i think is the model that we're
trying to do at isps health okay that it
isn't about partisanship or left and
right it's about evidence
and and that's what i would encourage
you to take away from this look at the
evidence see what works and see what
doesn't
try the aca don't try it but but see if
it works and see how
let that be what guides your opinions on
so so thanks for coming stay in touch
we're our website's
ispshealth.yale.edu so it's also it's
within isps.edu
it's under the
um and we won't ask you what your zodiac
sign is so so but thanks very much and
we'll stay in the back to answer
questions thank you zach
thank you john